Guten Morgen, liebe. Guten Morgen Tim.
Die Vergänglichkeit unserer Themen hier ist ja auch ziemlich hoch, da könnten wir ja eigentlich auch da ich auf Stepchat veröffentlichen, oder?
Yo. Was wollte ich dazu weiter sagen? Die Zeit war vorbei hier, das ist zu Ende gegangen.
Sag mal, wenn ich das jetzt hier, wenn ich das jetzt hier Snapchat will, ne? Wo ich.
Alter Mann, versagt mit neuen Medien.
Ich habe das jetzt zu My Story gesnapchat. Keine Ahnung, wer das jetzt sehen kann. Es ist eine Katastrophe, ey.
Das war das Schönste, das war das schöne schönste Twitterbild hinten, da ich noch am ersten Tag hier Publika, wo irgendwie so so dieser schöne Ausschnitt aus Pipe Fiction, wo der große, böse schwarze Mann so dieses Typen, die die.
Genau, die Knarre in die Fresse hält.
Say Snapchat, One More Time.
Es ist ja, es mag.
Ja, also ich würde das als ein User Interface Fail bezeichnen, dieses Snapchat. Ich habe das ja schon, ich habe jetzt sieben Punkte, ich weiß nicht genau, was man hier machen muss und viele Funktionen kommen immer so von der Seite rein und eh du dich, dann ist auf einmal.
Du kannst da sagen, was du willst, du du kommst äh immer wieder nur auf die selbe Diskussion raus.
Wir sind zu alt und die sind zu cool.
Genau und die Kinder mögen das und alles, was Kinder mögen, ist toll. Das ist nicht unsere Baust.
Das Einzige, was ich an Snapchat wird sich fand hast du dieses Video gesehen, Obama, wo Obama Obama in relativ witziges Video rausgebracht, wo er sich darüber Gedanken macht, äh,
Wasser jetzt irgendwie, weil er ja jetzt Zeit hat und so, ne? Dann läuft der irgendwie so beim Flur und der hält sich mit seinen Freunden, lässt sich Sachen empfehlen, ruft dann so Leute an und sagt so, hey, ich habe gehört, ihr sucht Leute, die legen dann auf und dann geht,
findet er irgendwie das Handy von seiner Tochter und macht Snapchat an und sagt so, Obama Case Great und hat aber irgend so einen Filter, wo ihm dann die ganze Zeit so Blut aus den Augen schießt und.
Das war glaube ich von diesem Presidence äh Prestinner. Ja, ja. Äh da da lief das Video. Ja,
Was übrigens sehr cool anfing, weil äh bevor er anfängt zu reden, haben sie halt die Musik eingespielt.
Und dann kommt er so ans Mikrofon und meint. Was vielleicht der beste Non-Menschen wie zu Donald Trump war ever.
Ja gut, aber also ich weiß auch nicht, wie wie zufrieden man jetzt auf die Präsidentschaft von Barack Obama zurückschauen soll, eigentlich ja überhaupt.
Licht und Schatten.
Ähm aber sagen wir mal so Humor ist, wenn man trotzdem nach acht Jahren US-Präsidentschaft überhaupt noch lachen kann und das gelingt ihm mit äh den Sachen, die er irgendwie so in dieser Präsidentschaft, die in der so.
Einen Heim gesucht haben und den äh wie er darauf reagiert hat, weiß ich nicht, ob ich noch lachen könnte. Insofern äh Glückwunsch.
Ja irgendwie mag ich ihn ja trotzdem.
Trotzdem, zu trotzdem kommen wir erst nach.
Ach so. Okay.
Also wir machen die Sachen natürlich nach wie immer in chronologischer Ordnung und nach Wichtigkeit sortiert. Äh wie heißt euer Podcast da? Stammtisch, den ihr da immer macht, Sub, Subscribe.
Der Stammtisch? Du meinst die nationale Konferenz und Workshopserie.
International.
Nee, international sind wir nicht. Doch wir sind insofern international, dass wir den deutschsprachigen Raum adressieren und damit äh natürlich auch äh Österreich, Schweiz und sonstige deutschsprachige Gebiete,
im Prinzip ansprechen. Ja, das fand am Wochenende statt, unsere siebte,
So, siebter Event, den wir dann halt großspurig subscribe sieben genannt haben, um das sozusagen auch gleich zu betonen, auch wenn die eine in dem Sinne noch gar nicht Subscribe hießen? Ja, das äh war wieder mal eine schöne Veranstaltung. Hundert Leute, gut besucht.
Wir haben da so ein schönes Wachstum in der Teilnehmerzahl und jetzt haben wir dann auch die Kapazitäten glaube ich der Räumlichkeiten ganz gut ausgereizt.
Jetzt geht's ja dann im Herbst weiter in München. Weiß nicht, ob.
In München.
Ja, wir ziehen mit der Veranstaltung nach München, also nicht dauerhaft.
Also international jetzt.
Einmalig jetzt wirklich international genau ähm und werden die nächste Veranstaltung vom vierzehnten bis zum sechzehnten Oktober abhalten in München in den Räumen,
des bayrischen Rundfunks. Ja. Einen großen Rundfunkradsaal. Ja, die haben da äh
uns das angeboten und äh nach eingehender Begutachtung stellten wir fest, dass äh dass es gut war und ähm ja da sind
tolle, tolle Räumlichkeiten, wo man den Event, so wie wir uns den äh vorstellen, noch sehr viel besser abfeiern kann als äh hier bisher,
Genau, warum nicht? Also das nehmen wir als Herausforderung an und das wird sicherlich auch cool. Also
von euch Podcast oder ein Podcasting generell Interesse hat dort Entwicklung betreibt oder auch nur ein generelles mediales Interesse an diesem Phänomen hat dann ist das im Oktober eure Veranstaltung.
Und bin nicht dann nicht. Wie das so ist.
Was ist denn Neues herausgekommen.
Na ja, es wurde äh geliegt mal wieder fleißig äh geliegt
letzte Woche hatte er auch noch eine andere Veranstaltung, nämlich die Republika, da werden wir noch so einiges zu erzählen, aber vor allem startete die Veranstaltung mit einem Knaller, den hat Greenpeace
vom Stapel gelassen und offenbar sind sie über einen Liker,
oder eine Liekerin ähm.
Papiere rangekommen, die äh den Verhandlungsstand zu dem TTIP-Abkommen zwischen den USA und Europa festhielten,
den allerletzten Stand, aber wo sowas wie den vorletzten Stand.
Stand April, Anfang April, jetzt ist.
In dem sich halt sozusagen wieder äh findet, wie so die die Positionen sind und dem war wohl zu entnehmen, dass diese Position dann doch
äh immer noch sehr unterschiedlich war, dass also Europa und Amerika da ähm nicht unbedingt äh alles schon auf einen gemeinsamen Nenner gebracht haben, sondern dass an manchen Stellen die Vorstellung der USA und Europa doch sehr weit auseinanderklaffen.
TTIP Trends, Atlantik, Trade and Investment Partnership. Früher tufter,
Trends Alentic Freed Frade Grement, aber weil Freetrade Agrements sich jetzt inzwischen überall als äh äh problematisch herausgestellt hat, Freihandelsabkommen, hat man es umbenannt? In der Hoffnung, dass es keiner merkt,
Wurde aber bemerkt,
und es gibt ja sehr viel äh Protest eigentlich seit seit langem dagegen. Wir hatten ja äh hier denke ich ähm eigentlich quasi eine Sondersendung, ein Spezial dazu.
Mit Kartasche.
Katascha. Ähm auf das wir glaube ich auch jetzt inhaltlich nochmal verweisen können, weil sich im Prinzip durch diese ähm Enthüllungen äh,
Das bewahrheitet hat oder das als wahr gezeigt hätte, was da äh befürchtet und besprochen wurde.
Genau, das ist Lokbuch, Netzpolitik einhundertdreißig mit dem schönen Titel Radikalisierung durch Interne.
Durch Internet, Eier, das war sehr schön. Ähm.
Jetzt worum geht's genau? Also die Reaktion darauf war erstmal, also es war ja immer ein riesiges Geschiss, diese Dinger geheim zu halten,
Aber jetzt natürlich wo es raus wo sie geliegt wurden, sagen dann die USA sie sind nicht beunruhigt, ähm die Bundesregierung will weitermachen und die EU-Kommission sagt ähm,
hat aber laut äh Gerüchtestand.
Recht große Zweifel, ob dieses TTIP überhaupt noch äh beschlossen werden kann, weil diese Dokumente eben zeigen, dass es da relativ wenig Annäherungen gibt, in der nun dreizehnten oder vierzehnten Verhandlungsrunde,
äh wo eben die beiden Parteien auf verschiedenen Positionen beharren.
Ähm am Brandenburger Tor hatte Greenpeace dann einen transparenten Leseraum für jedermann aufgebaut. Das war so ein großer Hänger,
dran, komplett drum herum, Glas entstand drauf, TTIP-Leseraum, eine Referenz an die Leseräume, die wir den einen TTIP-Leseraum, den es hier in Berlin auch gibt, wo dann,
Ich glaube früher nur mindesterialbeamte, dann nachher auch mal irgendwie,
Bundestagsabgeordnete rein durften, aber natürlich nie reingegangen sind, weil der irgendwie im Keller war und die Treppe gesperrt oder so. Und äh jetzt haben die eben am Brandenburger Tor hatten sie einen aufgestellt, der wurde natürlich dann auch, wie es sich für eine Greenpeace-Aktion gehört, äh irgendwann weggezerrt, weil sie den natürlich nicht genehmigt hatten
Ähm das fand ich, fand ich eigentlich sehr schön, da freut man sich ja auch immer, wie, wie.
Basteln Greenpeace, wenn die mal so eine Aktion machen.
Machen sie es auch gut.
Machen sie es gut und haben die offenbar auch einfach mal das Kapital und die Anwälte, um so eine Nummer einfach durchzuziehen. Ja, also ich glaube ähm.
Jetzt so hätten wir die geliegt, was weiß ich als.
Oder hätte irgendjemand anders aus der Netzcommunity, die geliegt hat, digitale Gesellschaft, CTC oder sonst was, ähm oder Netzpolitik Org, die hätten jetzt einfach nicht die Power gehabt,
Oder vielleicht auch nicht den Mut gehabt äh die paar tausend Euro oder die paar zehntausend Euro in die Hand zu nehmen für so eine,
für diese Fotos, ne? Das heißt, mach's ja nur für Fotos und um dir den am Ende wegprügeln zu lassen. Das ist ja äh das Ganze, also kann man gut machen, das ist halt schon schön, zu sehen, wenn dann so eine Ressourcen starke Organisation.
Also ich würde es jetzt im Club nicht so ganz absprechen. Ich äh erwähne an der Stelle zum Beispiel den schönen Bundestrojaner, der dann auch schon mal äh aufwendig sozusagen also es gab,
auch Objekt, Kunst. Also für.
Ohne Frage. Ich.
Ob's aber du hast schon recht, äh das zeichnet Greenpeace aus, dass sie an der Stelle auch ähm einen medialen Rundumschlag äh äh weit denken.
Das sind bezahlte Aktivisten, die,
das vernünftig machen, die Erfahrung haben und wo du gerade sagst, die eben eine Kampagne auch planen, die legen los und die haben Futter,
ne? Die liegen erstmal die Dokumente, dann stellen sie das Ding dahin, dann machen alle Fotos, dann lassen sie sich das da wegzerren und die wissen halt genau, wie man so eine Kampagne spielt
oder was heißt bezahlt hat
professionelle Campaigner, die wissen, wie man so ein Thema in der in der Luft hält. Aber kommen wir mal äh nochmals, warum äh sieht man,
oder warum sehen sie äh TTIP als Problem? Ähm in Europa,
Also wenn jemand ein Produkt auf den Markt bringen möchte, es ging da äh lange Zeit ja immer um diese Chlorhühner, womit sich ja letztendlich
der die TTIP-Gegner erstmal selbst ein Chlorei gelegt haben, äh weil das irgendwann auch lächerlich wurde,
Oder lächerlich gemacht wurde? In Europa hast du ein gilt ungefähr das Vorsorgeprinzip, das heißt ein Produkt, was du auf dem Markt bringst ist nur erlaubt
wenn es für Mensch und Umwelt nachweislich unschädlich ist. Wenn Mensch und Umwelt nachweislich unschädlich trifft jetzt auch nicht auf alle Produkte zu, aber,
ähm wenn du jetzt.
Ein anderer Ansatz.
Ist ein anderer Ansatz. Du musst Sachen prüfen, bevor du sie dem Markt zur Verfügung stellen kannst. Und ähm in den USA hast du eher so ein Risikoprinzip, das heißt verkauf erstmal und wenn dann die Leute sterben, dann können wir es immer noch vom Markt nehmen.
Ähm und,
dieses Risikoprinzip ist insbesondere in Bezug auf so Sachen wie Genmanipulation. Natürlich ähm sehr viel hilfreicher
um diese, um diese Nahrungs die gehen manipulierten Nahrungsmittel auf den Markt zu bringen, weil dir in Europa oder insbesondere in Deutschland halt jemand sagt so, ey, Alter,
was du da irgendwie genmanipuliert hast, keine Ahnung, wie lange man das essen kann oder ob das die Menschen mitgehen manipuliert. Äh während du in den USA halt großflächig den ganzen Mist anbauen kannst.
In Deutschland ähnlich ähm.
Aber es geht eben um um grundsätzlichen Ansatz, der der da zwischen diesen beiden ähm Staaten oder Staatengemeinschaften zu ähm vereinheitlichen ist.
Und wenn du jetzt so ein Abkommen, wenn du jetzt ein solches Abkommen hast
zwischen diesen beiden großen Wirtschaftsmächten. Ich zitiere da jetzt mal äh sinngemäß Herr Ribert Branden in der Süddeutschen Zeitung, der ist sehr schön äh zusammengefasst, das
geht es um ein Abkommen, das ungefähr vierzig Prozent des gesamten Welthandels betrifft, dass der dann unter dieses Titip fällt. Und.
Das heißt, damit wird die gesamte transatlantische Wirtschaftsordnung geregelt und eben,
Ja, mit fast die Hälfte des des Weltmarktes. Und,
Was sie da, worauf sie sich einigen sollen, ist dann ja quasi sowas wie eine Wirtschaftsverfassung, so eine super Ordnung
wo du sagst, so quasi, du hast die Hager Landkriegsordnung
du hast T-Tipp, ja? Und alles andere macht ihr macht ihr irgendwie äh dürfen, da dürfen die Staaten dann eben nicht mehr gegen verstoßen. Und,
das geheime oder das fürchterliche Wort da drin, je nachdem wie man's sieht, ist eben das, was sie äh regulatorische Kooperationen nennen. Das nämlich, um zu verhindern, dass.
Ein Land der beiden oder der Beteiligten.
Ein Gesetz verabschiedet, dass einem anderen Land der Beteiligten ein Handelshemmnis äh entstehen lassen würde.
Geht es nur setzen sie sich schon vorher zusammen und diskutieren das aus. Das heißt, du hast nicht was,
Lange Zeit ja auch im äh im Vordergrund stand diese Geheimgerichte,
Oder diese Schiedsgerichte, wo dann ein Land oder der Staat eines Landes gegen einen anderen Staat oder eine ein Unternehmen des Einlandes gegen einen Staat in einem anderen oder im gleichen Land klagen kann, wegen eines Handelshemmnisses,
sondern die streben sogar an, sich vorher schon zusammenzusetzen, zu verhindern, dass die einzelnen Staaten überhaupt jemals solche Gesetze schreiben.
Also mehr oder.
Position, die sich derzei.
Das ist die Position TTIP. Ähm und das wird quasi verstanden als ein.
Als ein lebendes Abkommen, das dann im Laufe äh des Zeites äh im Laufe der Zeit in Expertenausschüssen beständig fortentwickelt werden soll.
Und äh diese Expertenausschüsse sollen dann eben auch verhindern, dass äh Gesetze erlassen werden, die im Widerspruch zum Freihandelsabkommen stehen.
Ja, also eine Verschwörung der Nationen. Ne, also hier äh die die EU-Staaten und ähm,
Und der der USA zur Begünstigung des Welthandels oder des Handels zwischen diesen Nationen. Jetzt ist eben die Frage, ähm wie man überhaupt zu den zu Ideen des Handels steht. Es ist sicherlich immer.
Für für irgendjemanden positiv, wenn etwas verkauft wird oder wenn Handels äh Barrieren ähm sinken, entsprechend.
Applaudiert ja auch die äh die deutsche Autoindustrie, ja,
die äh der dem TTIP-Abkommen, also die kritisieren äh die Veröffentlichung der Geheimdokumente schärfstens, der Chef des Branchenverbands VDA, Matthias Wissmann ähm.
Warf dieser Aktion gezielte Stimmungsmache vor. Meine Güte, wer hätte das denken können, dass Greenpeace gezielte Stimmungsmacher im Rahmen ihrer eigenen,
politischen Interessen macht es ja völlig unvorstellbar.
Shocking News, das.
Mit der Veröffentlichung von Verhandlungszwischenständen werden bewusst Ängste geschürt, um das gesamte Vorhaben zu diskreditieren, so wissmann. Es gehe nämlich, also ist das schon mal witzig, ja. Verhandlungszwischenstände, ja, da,
Er gibt quasi direkt schon zu, dass es Verhandlungszwischenstände sind. Ja und dass die stimmen, dass das im Moment die der Stand der Verhandlungen ist und dass man damit
bewusst Ängste schüren würde, was für ein Unsinn. Ich meine, wenn das der Zwischenstand ist, dann ist es doch genau wichtig, wenn der den Leuten Angst macht, den vorher zu veröffentlichen. Also ist witzig, witzig. Und dann sagt er aber es geht nicht darum, Sozialprodukt oder Umweltstandards aufzuweichen.
Sondern Doppelregulierungen und Bürokratie abzubauen.
Das klingt ja immer gut. Bürokratieabbau.
Das klingt immer sehr schön ähm Bürokratieabbau ist sicherlich was, woran man Interesse hat, wenn man Welthandel betreiben möchte, äh Doppelregulierung ist auch
ist tatsächlich ärgerlich, ne? Also es gibt ja irgendwie diese diese Beispiele, wenn du jetzt ein Auto verkaufen willst in dem da sind die sind Autos eben so gespeckt, dass die Blinker einen bestimmten Abstand haben, müssen wir die die Scheinwerfer eine bestimmte Höhe und so gibt's tatsächlich Unterschiede,
zwischen den äh Import und Exportvarianten und so und das ist tatsächlich mit einem hohen.
Komplexitätsgrad äh behaftet. Ähm.
Gegen internationale Standards ist ja generell grundsätzlich.
Internationale Standardsuche. Da haben wir so eine Iso für, da kann man das alles wunderschön reinfügen. Ähm.
Aber das muss man ja nicht unbedingt gleich zum äh Primat der der politischen Beziehung äh machen.
Genau und wenn du jetzt da, wenn du was er auch selber anspricht, sozial,
Standards, Produktstandards und Umweltstandards sind eben von Land zu Land unterschiedlich und die sind per se Handelshemmnisse. Ein Sozialstandard ist ein Handelshemmnis, weil er dir die Arbeits äh die die ähm.
Weil er dir die die Lohnkosten in die Höhe treibt, die Lohnnebenkosten. Ein Produktstandard ist ein handelshemmdes, weil er dich zwingt, das Produkt, einem gewissen, einem gewissen Qualitätsgrad ähm erreichen zu lassen,
der mitunter nicht,
monetär kompensiert wird, sondern einfach nur gesetzlich vorgeschrieben ist, dass du keine Wirkgiftstoffe in deinem Plastik hast und äh
Ein Umweltstandard ähm ist natürlich auch,
Gewinnhemden, weil er für dich eine Investition darstellt, äh bevor du dein Video dein Produkt zu fertigen hast und du nicht einfach äh diese Soße in innen reinkippen kannst. Ähm.
Und genau gegen solche Standards so die Befürchtung und so diese Befürchtung sehen viele in den aktuellen Diskussionsständen bestätigt werden unter dieses Einkommen. Äh unter dieses Abkommen fallen und dann klagen sie dir die halt weg.
Oder du kriegst diese Standards gar nicht mehr, weil da der Expertenausschuss sagt, na nee, also hör mal
Also jetzt hier genmanipuliertes Essen zu verbieten äh oder eine Kennzeichnungspflicht für genmanipuliertes Essen
Das sehen wir natürlich durchaus als Handelshemmnis für unsere ganzen Genmanipulierten äh Nahrungsmittel, die wir bei euch auf den Markt werfen wollen. Das geht natürlich so nicht.
Ja, also ist auch schön wie sowas wie Handelshemmdes, so als so ein Begriff dargestellt wird, so so negatives negatives Ding, ja? Oh,
alle Entdeckungen,
wenn man halt keine Handelshemmnisse hat, dann hat man halt eine Handelsenthemmung und da,
Das kann ja nun auch nicht unbedingt immer die Antwort sein. Ich würde auch euer noch nicht mal sagen, dass es jetzt generell nicht erstrebenswert wäre, eine Harmonisierung
der
ähm wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen und auch der wirtschaftlichen Realitäten, die wie sie sich halt in äh Standards et cetera und eben Regularien und letztlich auch Bürokratie niederschlägt, dass man das nicht verbessern soll,
Die Frage ist nur ist TTIP in seinem Umfang ähm der geeignete Weg oder gibt es nicht,
die Möglichkeit viele dieser kleinen Dinge, die dort angestrebt sind, einfach auch in ähm weniger groß aufgeblasenen Abkommen Schritt für Schritt herzuleiten, was sicherlich auch einfacher zu verhandeln wäre.
Also ich meine es ist ja nicht so, dass dass das unbedingt als Paket kommen muss. Und ich glaube, das ist auch das, was so vielen, wie ich finde, auch zu Recht ähm,
ja Angst, vielleicht nicht das richtige Wort, aber wo sozusagen viele Leute,
Zurückhaltung ausüben, dass man ja hier äh diverse Katzen im Sack kaufen soll und unter der,
vorgeschobenen Argumentation ja hier, ihr kriegt ja äh alle Cookies, ja? So, dass man dann halt hintenrum sich eben auch eher unverdauliches mit eintritt und das ist halt das Problem. Ich denke halt auch nicht, dass das, sagen wir mal,
einen moderner Ansatz sein sollte. Also,
sehe nicht unbedingt die Notwendigkeit, dass man immer alles in so riesige Pakete schnürt, sondern es ist eigentlich viel sinnvoller, jeden Bereich für sich selber zu behandeln und dann,
Kommt man da irgendwann ja vielleicht auch mal dahin, aber dann kann man das eben auch viel einfacher diskutieren,
muss es vor allem nicht unter so einem Geheimhaltungspakt äh ausüben. Glaub das ist auch das, was gerade dieser ganzen.
TTIP-Geschichte so sehr, also egal wie die jetzt argumentieren, einfach die Tatsache, dass es sich hier um Geheimverhandlung handelt,
Das ist etwas, wogegen sich dieser, wo sich dieser Widerstand,
Der mag ja dann im Einzelnen vielleicht auch ungerechtfertigt sein, nur wenn man halt nicht weiß, worüber man eigentlich redet, dann dann gibt's halt erstmal Kontra,
und an der Stelle ist Transparenz geboten und die ist halt hier überhaupt nicht vorhanden.
Wollen wir noch ein bisschen weiter über die Republika reden?
Können wir machen. Ich muss zugeben, also ich war ja äh ein wenig eingebunden, weil wir äh,
mit unserem,
Sendezentrum ja auch einen kleinen Ort bekleidet haben. Das war jetzt nichts Großes. Wir haben eigentlich nichts weiter gemacht als so eine Anlaufstelle zu sein für
Podcastszene, das war eigentlich auch ganz nett, dass die Republiker uns da die Gelegenheit gegeben hat. Das war ja dann deutlich mehr Platz,
vorhanden in dieser äh mittleren Halle, die so in den letzten Jahren immer so furchtbar zugestellt war mit so äh Abertausenden Buden, also die,
Sponsorenpräsenz war zum gefühlt nicht so groß, was diesen Raum betraf. Von daher war halt noch äh Platz frei und das ist insofern auch ein guter Move,
dass dort auch Community-Projekten, zumindest in unserem Fall Raum gegeben wird.
Ansonsten gab's auch ein paar Veränderungen, ähm die ich durchaus begrüße, nämlich,
nicht mehr so irre, viele Bühnen.
Was? Das war noch jetzt viel mehr, siebzehn Stück oder so.
Nee, das war schon mal mehr. Also es äh.
Wir hatten schon mal mehr.
Der.
Also zumindest, was auf jeden Fall abgeschafft wurde, waren diese unsäglichen äh Doppelaufteilungen der großen Halle, also zum Beispiel dieser Saal zwei war in den letzten zwei Jahren immer zwei oder ich glaube sogar einmal drei Säle,
Also sozusagen drei Tracks, die da parallel liefen, die aber auch akustisch miteinander äh sich gegenseitig überstreiten. Was dann eben zu so besonders absurden Situationen führten, also und und dann wurden ja diese Kopfhörer ausgegeben,
sodass man die Talks nur über Kopfhörer hören konnte. Das heißt, du saß da, hast einen Funkkopfhörer aufgehabt und die äh präsentierende Person sprach halt in das äh Mikrofon, hörte sich auch selber nur über Kopfhörer. Also eine völlig,
unangenehme Grundsituation gemacht hat, weil du halt einfach keinerlei Reaktion des Publikums mehr so direkt unmittelbar mitbekommen hast und dass du dich in so einem so einem so einem, so ein Clean Rom irgendwie äh befunden hast
und trotzdem hörtest du dann aber immer noch äh das Klatschen, Gelächter und sonstige emotionale Reaktionen von anderen Bühnen,
einfach so zu so vollkommen unangenehmen Situationen geführt hat, dass was ich vielleicht auch gerade so ein total dramatisches Thema, der Tod von Menschen, weißt du so so Dramen geschildert worden und dann so
johlendes Geklatsche vom vom Nachbarsaal eingestreut wurde und du dann in der Aufzeichnung,
Nein, das gab sie dieses Jahr nicht mehr so.
Ja, ja, ne, das das wurde ja auch eingesehen, dass das einfach extrem kontraput, also weil das ja auch in den Aufzeichnungen dann so rüber kam. Und äh die natürlich ein vollkommen falsches Bild lieferten.
Also ich habe die, das war jetzt die zehnte Republika. Und ähm ich glaube, also es war.
Die ist jetzt neun Jahre alt, um das gleich mal dazu zu sagen.
Ja, aber es war die zehnte Republika und ich kann nicht genau sagen, wie viele Republiken ich besucht habe. Ähm,
Ich glaub die ersten drei oder vier nicht die ersten drei wahrscheinlich nicht.
Und dann letztes Jahr habe ich festgestellt, weil ich auch nicht da, war ich unterwegs. Ähm ich habe diese Veranstaltung nie so.
Richtig verstanden. Ich hatte immer ähm ich habe irgendwie, ich habe die nicht hundertprozentig verstanden. Und.
Also im Vergleich zu einer Veranstaltung wie äh wie dem Congress
die ich vollständig verstehe oder auch so Werbemessen, wo die man immer auch vollständig versteht. Er hat sich mit dieses Konzept Republika so richtig nie ganz erschlossen
Ähm aber dieses Jahr hat das irgendwann mal,
Als ich da war Klick gemacht, dass ich meine verstanden zu haben, was die Bedeutung dieser Veranstaltung ist. Wird ja immer gesagt, ja, hier Blogger treffen und äh solche Scherze.
Und dann gibt's also bei dem es gibt dann irgendwie so ja das ist das Bloggertreffen und dann kommen da die Blogger hin
Und dann sagen die Blogger, öh voll scheiße, äh das IPM hier sponsort oder voll doof, dass äh BMW oder oder wer auch immer da jetzt äh der Sponsor ist. Ähm.
Und dann ist das, ist da das Große, dann ist da das große äh gequengellos. Das war ja und dann hast du ja auch irgendwie immer wieder Leute, die jetzt sage ich mal auf
Auf Nonkommerz stehen, äh die dann eben sagen so, ja nee so Kommerzveranstaltungen, so wollen wir unter gar keinen Umständen haben und so, ne, denn die Republika als Commerz-Veranstaltung kritisieren.
Was sie aber von Anfang an war, ja, also es ist auch wirklich so, wenn dir nach zehn Jahren auffällt, dass da äh dass es da Sponsoren gibt und dass diese äh dass die dass diese Veranstaltung anstrebt, ihre diejenigen, die da äh Vollzeit dran arbeiten
irgendwie auch zu bezahlen, dann äh hast du lange Zeit was verpasst.
Was die Repolika irgendwie hinkriegt, ist aber genau das, nämlich in diesen Kreisen relevant zu sein. Wenn jetzt irgendwie die, also diejenigen, die die Republika sponsoren.
Die machen das ja inzwischen nicht mehr, weil sie denken, ach cool, da können wir mal ein kleines äh so ein kleines Trinksponsoren. Das machen wir mal. Das ist ja, sieht ja ganz nett aus. Da können wir uns dran äh green waschen oder so,
sondern die machen das tatsächlich.
Weil sie's wollen und müssen, weil das eine relevante Veranstaltung ist. Wo sie Präsenz zeigen müssen. Deutsche Telekom äh war Sponsor, Daheimler und so weiter, die wollen da hin.
Und.
Die Leute, die da arbeiten oder die da irgendwie äh Produktmanagement oder äh Social Media oder sonst was machen. Für die ist das die coolste Veranstaltung des Jahres,
weil die nämlich sonst auf irgendwelchen Messen rumhängen.
Irgendwie was weiß ich Demex Quo oder solche Geschichten die wirklich von oben bis unten durch kommerzialisiert sind und wo alle nur noch äh
da sich darüber Gedanken machen, einerseits möglichst viele Visitenkarten zu sammeln, andererseits Visitenkarten in diese Schalen zu werfen, wo iPads verlost werden
und ähm die Republika schafft es, dieses gesamte Völkchen da hinzukriegen.
Und den zumindest in irgendeiner Form so eine Art Wir Gefühl und eine positiven Blick in die Zukunft zu geben,
Zum Beispiel eben da einfach mal Netzpolitik Org mit einem mit einem ordentlichen Stand hinzustellen und ihre Landesfahrrad äh Shirts verkaufen zu lassen. Ne?
Jetzt kann man natürlich klar Markus Beckedal ist Mitbegründer der Republika
Selbstverständlich hat er jetzt kein kein Geld für diesen Stand da bezahlt von der Politik Ork, ne? Ähm ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus, dass äh das Sendezentrum auch sein stand da äh nicht teuer bezahlen musste,
Und ich weiß aber, dass die jene Unternehmen, die da irgendwie Goldsponsor sind oder sowas, die mussten natürlich ordentlich da rein, Becher äh äh reinblättern, um um sich dort äh positionieren zu können und die,
Die Mischung ist irgendwie interessant, dass diese Unternehmen nämlich auch nicht da wären, wenn nämlich eben sowas wie äh wie Netzpolitik Ork diese Gras Roots Dinger eben nicht auch da wären. Und die
quer finanzieren sie halt dadurch.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich mein Eindruck ist für diese ganzen Leute, die irgendwie ein Produktmanagement äh Social Media Kram und so weiter tätig sind, die müssen auf ganz andere Veranstaltungen gehen, wo es wirklich wo es richtig eklig ist,
Und für die ist die Republik ja echt so die Oberoffenbarung, weil das da halt echt einfach mal cool ist,
Und diesen Hack ähm der jetzt ja seit zehn Jahren so stattfindet, den finde ich echt ähm dann auch mal beachtlich.
Da hat er sich natürlich hinbewegt, das war's von Anfang an nicht. Ich war auf allen Republikas und habe das halt ganz gut mitbekommen, wie sich das so entwickelt hat, die äh ersten zwei Male waren definitiv,
Erstmal sowas wie was weiß ich, so wie unsere Subscribe. Da hat sich halt einfach so eine Community getroffen. Es war halt gleich relativ breit angelegt, ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau, ich glaube auf der ersten waren so siebenhundert Leute oder sowas in der Größenordnung und ähm muss sagen, ich fand die,
Das ging allen so. Die Atmosphäre auf der ersten Republika war einfach fantastisch. Also es war wirklich eine eine ganz, ganz, ganz tolle,
irre, geile Atmosphäre da, weil du natürlich im Prinzip so alle diese neuen New Influencer,
Blogger, wie du auch sie auch immer nennen möchtest, waren halt da und ich äh ich bin ja auch dieses Jahr gebeten worden auf der Eröffnungsveranstaltung kurz,
was zu sagen, habe ich dann auch getan.
Und habe auch bin so ein bisschen darauf eingegangen, eben auf genau dieses äh Gefühl, weißt du, so dieser Moment, wo wenn du wenn du feststellst, dass alle Leute anfangen übers nächste Mal zu reden.
Wo du einfach merkst, so alle die da sind, sind so der Meinung so, ja
warum warum gab es das nicht schon längst so, ne? Äh das das müssen wir jetzt beibehalten. Das Wachstum, was die Republiker dann durchgemacht hat, war schwierig,
Weil du natürlich, wenn du nicht so wie der CCC, sag mal sehr müssig, sich mit dem mit dem Club und dem Kongress äh insbesondere zu vergleichen, ja. Wenn du nicht so eine riesige Community hast, die so mit,
entsprechende Opferbereitschaft und und Jugendlichen Engagement so eine Veranstaltung äh trägt und damit eben auch weitgehend unabhängig von so einem Sponsorentum macht. Wenn du auf sowas nicht setzen kannst und das das konnte eben,
auch das Umfeld von von Spreeblick und Netzpolitik Ork hat nur in bedingten Maße äh dann musste der natürlich für dein Wachstum,
Was ja im Prinzip von außen schlicht durch Interesse entgegengetragen wird, ne? Du musst ja, musst dir immer irgendwie antworten. Du kannst ja sagen, nö, wir bleiben eine geschlossene Gruppe und wir unterhalten uns jetzt hier einfach nur
unter uns, ja und wer auf der ersten Republiker war, der kriegt auch für die zweite Ticket, so kannst du damit ja nicht.
Das wäre vor allem fatal gewesen, die wenn ich da mal ganz kurz einhaken darf, dass dass diese Community ja, diese Netz,
Dingen Star, überhaupt 'ne Möglichkeit, also überhaupt ein Gehör noch findet bei diesem Konzern,
Und überhaupt noch die Vision der Zukunft. Weißt du, wenn die dann, wenn dann da die Sponsor-Talks irgendwie sind? Ja, hier Industrie vier null und Cloud fünf null und Virtual Reality sechs null und und was wird hier und Basswort da? Dass da am.
Und Snapchat und was nicht so, ne? Dass da überhaupt noch irgendwie am Ende die alle sitzen und sich so ein Logo anhören. Und ähm.
Oder viele andere Talks ja oder eben ein Markus Beckedal ähm mit seinen mit seinen journalistischen Tätigkeiten, ja? Und dass dass diese Leute überhaupt noch wahrnehmen und kennen,
Und ähm.
Andersrum im Prinzip sozusagen auch schon zu zu Popsas eigentlich äh aufgestiegen sind.
Genau und diese Leute, die eben am Ende auch sich denen zugehörig fühlen,
Vor allem egal wo sie in zwei Jahren das Produktmanagement machen, ne? Die gehen weiterhin zu Republika und die haben da eine Community und ein Zuhause das ist doch hauptsächlich des Verdienst dieser Veranstaltung.
Die Veranstaltung ist relevant in diesen Bereichen. Die sponsern das für die Irren, die gehen da gerne hin und die äh die die haben dann noch ein Wir-Gefühl.
Ja und uns gibt auch ein paar andere, also was hier auch so in den letzten Jahren auch schon so aus äh Gesprächen äh herausgehört habe, insbesondere so mit Freunden, die eigentlich so, ne?
So wie wir sind, sage ich mal. Ja, also die sagen wir mal etwas lockeren äh äh Umgang mit der Welt äh pflegen und im Prinzip aber mit dem anderen Bein auch in dieser Businesswelt stehen, weil sie da irgendwie anerkannte Berater sind, weil sie halt einfach,
im Projektmanagement machen, was auch immer, aber im Wesentlichen dann immer auch mit größeren Unternehmen zu tun haben und da auch mal so so einen gewissen Grundschmerz erleiden, weil einfach da diese Prozesse äh ne, einfach schwierig sind und einfach
man einfach nie so agil da denkt, wie wie wir das so mit unserer Internetprägung äh für Selbstverständlich halten,
Die berichten dann auch immer davon, wenn dann diese Unternehmen dann irgendwie die Leute dahin geschickt bekommen. So und die ja eigentlich, wie du schon sagtest, eigentlich immer nur so Langweiler, Standard,
gehen wir ins Hotel und dann war irgendwie einen langweiligen Konferenzen rum und dann schauen wir uns noch die paar aller Weltstände an, die da sind und daten der werden ausgegeben. Wenn die dann auf die Republika kommen,
Wo ja der der Schlips, also ich ich hast du da jemanden mit einem Schlips gesehen.
Wenn dann hätte ich's nicht.
Also dieses Jahr habe ich also irgendeiner wird sicherlich.
Von der Neo Neo wie heißt der William Cohen oder sowas? Keine Ahnung was denn? Er hat da einen Schlips an.
Keine Ahnung, also meine Vintage, wenn wenn Schlips da trägst auf der Republika, dann ist das wahrscheinlich auch schon wieder irgendwie so so popkulturelles Signal.
Also ich werde, ich wäre jetzt vorsichtig, könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass.
Ja, aber es ist halt einfach mal nicht der Standard so. Das das kann man wirklich festhalten
so, ne? Da ist einfach ein anderer Umgang am Start, da ist eine andere Diskussionskultur am Start. Und selbst wenn man jetzt äh dann im Einzelnen beschreit, dass irgendwelche durchgedrehten
Business Hipster da auch auf der Bühne wieder Performance hinlegen, wo man sich einfach nur noch an Kopf fasst, so
Draußen ist ja schon Uhrzeit. Ein Vogel vom Privatradio da war einfach,
Irgendjemand meldete sich danach, wo in der QA-Session und meinte so, du bist so, wie ich mir jemand vom Privatradio immer vorgestellt habe
Ja, war auch schon geile Kommentarkultur. Also das ist in gewisser Hinsicht auch eine Heranführung der Schlipswelt.
An die Realität. Und das finde ich.
Oh, das äh das finde ich, das finde ich aber echt ganz ich würde das vielleicht bin ich ja zu pessimistisch, aber ich würde fast sagen, das ist eine Heranführung der Nerds an die Realität.
Kommt drauf an, welche Realität du hälst, als die richtige äh äh erachtest. Ich habe das jetzt mal aus meiner Perspektive formuliert, aber ähm.
Man kann die Präsenz beklagen, aber man kann halt auch sagen, es ist ein Forum, in der man denen.
Die die das Ungewöhnliche nicht leben auch mal zeigen kann wie das auch geht.
Dass es auch äh äh möglich ist, über solche Themen zu reden, dass man in der Lage ist.
Sich vielleicht auch über Business Gedanken zu machen, aber sich eben genauso und auch in einem direkten Zusammenhang über politische gesellschaftliche,
Fragen der Verantwortung und der Zukunftsplanung Gedanken machen kann und dass sich das nicht unbedingt zwangsläufig widersprechen muss. Und das finde ich auch ganz gut und das steht steht für mich auch,
äh bin großer Fan von diesem Namen. Finde,
Finde Republik auf jeden Fall einen grandiosen äh Titel für für eine Konferenz. Äh für mich stand das in diesem Namen auch von Anfang an drin
Dieser Anspruch, ich meine auf der einen Seite halt es halt so ein bisschen so dieses internetige Reh und Doppelpunkt, nimm's Bases und und Publika und wir publizieren und so, ja, so ein bisschen Netzpublikation, das stand so ein bisschen am Anfang. Aber ich,
Unterstelle diesen Namen, dieser Namensfindung, mich da mit dem ehrlich gesagt noch nie drüber unterhalten, aber für mich war das auch immer klar, dass man eben auch sagt.
Wir liefern jetzt auch unseren neuen Blick auf die Gesellschaft,
Wir wir diskutieren hier unter anderem auch über die Republik, über über unser unser Gemeinwesen und an der Stelle.
Liefert die Republika auch immer wieder Gutes, TTIP Leaks ist ein gutes Beispiel, es gab viele andere Beispiele in den Jahr.
Ja, du irgendwo mehr, das, dann war jetzt irgendwie äh das war jetzt irgendwie Greenpeace, die das gemacht haben, ne.
Ja, aber Greenpeace macht's halt auf dieser Veranstaltung und es passt zu dieser Veranstaltung. Okay. Ja, es gäbe viele Veranstaltungen, die hätten da äh Greenpeace bestimmt nicht eingeladen, da auf Saal eins irgendwie eine Kino zu machen.
Reden wir mal von einer Keynote Insaal eins. Edward Snowden, live zugeschaltet auf Stage fünf. Was war das?
Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Ich hab's auch nicht gesehen. Ich beklage, dass ihr aber ich weiß auch nicht, ob Stage fünf überhaupt aufgezeichnet wird. Also wie da ist mir dann schon irgendwie, da wird mir dann da wunder ich mich dann schon.
Was über die Stage.
Ja. War also für Edward Snone kann es nur Stage eins geben.
Ähm.
Und wenn Stage fünf größer als Stage eins ist, dann hat Stage fünf Stage Stage eins zu heißen.
Ja größer war es jetzt fünf bestimmt nicht. Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht ganz genau, wo äh die fünf war. Ähm ich war nie in der fünf.
Ich auch nicht, aber äh also es gibt ein.
Fünf ist auch nicht ganz klein. Ähm.
Das mag sein, dass das nicht so klein ist. Also ich habe hier irgendwie eine.
Aber ist nicht so groß wie.
Ein grob Zusammenschnitt von.
Nichtsdesto groß wie eins. Zwei ist auch größer noch als.
Aufzeichnung davon, ja? Also kann ich möchte ich kritisieren. Ähm.
Kann ich nicht beurteilen, was da jetzt der Hintergrund war.
Dann gibt's immer den Klasse, ist mir auch völlig egal. Ja, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
Ja ein bisschen mehr auch, aber wenn du das schon so ansprichst.
Na, ich wir es gibt keinen Hintergrund, der entschuldigen will, dass AdWords Noten nicht auf Insaal einspricht.
Außer dass allgemein zu beklagen ist, dass eben Ott Edwardsnoden seine Besonderheiten als Keynote Speaker oder so eben jetzt auch leider inzwischen so ein bisschen ausgespielt hat, was
auch sehr schade ist.
Ähm es war anfangs, das weiß ich zufällig aus eigener Kongresserfahrung zu berichten. Äh relativ schwierig, Edwards Norden als Speaker für deine Veranstaltung zu bekommen.
Deswegen hat er ja auch nie auf dem Kongress war bisher.
Genau. Ähm.
Vor allem am Anfang nicht, weil das ja durchaus auf der Liste stand.
Wir hatten ja auch höhere Ziele, also wir wollten jetzt den Videoschalter oder so hätten wir als Backup auch gemacht. So, aber ähm.
Es war anfangs relativ schwierig, aber ich habe das zum ersten Mal beobachtet bei diesem Logo-Symposium hier in Berlin, äh wo Snowden live geschaltet war, in Saal eins und dieser Saal nicht voll war.
Oh ich dachte, was ist denn hier los? Dieses gesamte Ding hatte ja eigentlich nur Snowden, Themen äh zum Inhalt die gesamte Veranstaltung.
Die Veranstaltung war ja an sich nicht. Also da war gar nichts voll. Eins vorzukriegen. Ja, war das so?
Ja, da waren aber trotzdem genug Leute, um Saal eins vollzukriegen. Da ja, das habe ich ja daran gemerkt, dass nicht irgendwelche lärmenden Arschgeigen vom Flur noch dabei gestört haben. Der Veranstaltungen zu folgen,
ja ähm.
Okay.
Also das das betrachte ich äh mit mit äh,
Unzufriedenheit. Äh Sascha Lobo natürlich als äh einer der Speaker auf der äh Republika äh sehr gut besucht.
Ähm hat dann die Age oft trotzdem äh indem er im Prinzip schon so ein, ja, eine eine Niederlage ähm.
Oder viele Niederlagen ähm.
Eingesteht dieser Bewegung. Natürlich sagt, sind das immer nur die anderen, die das verkackt haben eher nicht. Ähm.
Und dann aber eben so zu so ein ein trotziges trotzdem äh als,
Als Schlachtruf ausruft, finde ich, also sind sowieso immer äh sehr gut seine Vorträge. Ich ich weiß, ich so dieses dieses.
Ja doch sehr arrogant, diese arrogante Persona, mit der er da spielt weiß ich nicht, ob die ob er die nicht einfach manchmal ein bisschen zu dick aufträgt, aber das ist eine Stilfrage inhaltlich ähm,
ist das äh wie immer ein sehr interessanter Vortrag, weil er ja auch äh er findet immer noch irgendwo so einen Vergleich, den noch keiner hatte und äh das ist schon äh wie immer sehenswert.
Äh dann gab's noch einen Vortrag, äh den ich ganz äh ganz schön fand oder auf den ich mich auch schon lange gefreut hatte
Wusste so ein bisschen, dass der stattfinden würde. Von Thorsten Schröder und Frank Rieger vom Chaos-Computerclub
über AdWars, wo sie also sagen, okay, wie funktioniert das, ne? Was ist hier eigentlich diese Problematik mit den mit der Werbung auf den Seiten? Und sie haben dann als Experiment.
Ähm.
Eine Seite gebaut, die Seite für so ein Werbefenst, für so Werbeplatz angeboten.
Und dann selber Werbung auf ihrer Seite gekauft,
Ja, also du hast die haben einen Werbebanner auf einer eigenen Seite geschaltet. Und das äh kannst du natürlich machen, ne? Ist ja jetzt im Werbenetzwerk ja egal. Du du kannst der Bannerplatz steht zum Verkauf, du mietest den,
und dann machen die den Mann in Kram für dich. Ob du jetzt bei dir selber Werbung schaltest oder nicht.
Wir haben sich eigentlich verhindert, dass da irgendeine andere Werbung kommt außer ihre?
Na er hat ja niemand anders da geschaltet. Ne, also ganz einfach die Seite hat ja die hat hier.
Tomatisch so angeboten, okay. Die war uninteressant äh ok.
Bushalt mit höherer Priorität oder bietest mehr pro Einblendung und dann äh wird da nur deine eingezeigt. So und da haben sie zwei Werbeanzeigen geschaltet, einmal äh für die haben wenige Leute verstanden,
Einmal äh für das äh von Leitner in,
für verteiltes Echtzeitjahr und einmal für die äh Lightover Copa Technology fand ich beides sehr schön.
Wie wir ja wissen.
Licht, Licht über Kupfer, das wird das nächste große Ding.
Ist.
Und ähm diese beiden Edbanner hatten einfach beide Einnahmen eine Sicherheitslücke in einem Browser ausgebenutzt, um dann.
Local äh also Remote Code Execution zu bekommen, das heißt ähm das klassische Beispiel, wie man sowas immer demonstriert ist, man macht den äh ähm den Kalkulator auf, Kalk Echse, also.
Auf Windows, das ist immer so das Beispiel für Yo okay, du hast ich kann hier
Befehle ausführen. Ich habe Code Execution. Und da kannst du natürlich statt äh Kalkexe, kannst natürlich auch sagen, lad mal folgende Datei herunter und für sie aus. Ja, also in dem Moment kannst du eine Infektion äh des Systemes vornehmen,
Das haben sie an zwei Beispielen demonstriert, einmal mit irgendeiner Uhr als Sicherheitslücke in ähm in Firefox und dann mit einer Sicherheitslücke in einem XPI, also in einem, in einer Browser Extension.
Selbst geschrieben.
Selber geschrieben haben, aber diese Sicherheitssucke könnte eben auch in jeder anderen Browser-Extension drin sein. Und zum zum zu Browser Extensions kommen wir gleich nochmal im Detail, das heißt jeder,
jede Browser-Extension, die ihr installiert.
Ist erweitert, um erweitert die Angriffsoberfläche eures Browsers, die ihr ohnehin schon enorm ist, weil so ein Browser heute schon irgendwie Komplexitätsgrade hat wie vor zehn, fünfzehn Jahren Betriebssysteme nicht hatten. Ähm.
Diese Adnetzwerke sind eben deshalb supikant, weil du damit dich im Prinzip auf jeder vielbesuchten Seite einfach einbuchen kannst. Wenn ich jetzt,
eine solche Sicherheitslücke im Zero Daybereich habe, dann kann ich problemlos,
Spiegel online oder welche Seite auch immer Werbung schalten, solange die nicht irgendwie sittenwidrig ist. Da gibt's keine oder was weiß ich deren den Designgestaltungen im Rahmen der Brust äh und so weiter nicht äh widerspricht,
kann ich das schalten, da gibt's kaum jemanden, der das kontrolliert.
Insbesondere nicht das Werbenetzwerk, die machen da jetzt nicht irgendwie sowas wie ein Test, ob da ein Exploid drin ist und wenn sie's machen würden, könnten sie's auch nicht wirklich.
Zero Day, würden sie gar nicht finden und verschleiern lassen sich natürlich auch schon bekannte Explods.
Das heißt, du kannst wunderschön ähm über diese Werbung eine ganze Menge ähm Nutzer erreichen.
Nicht nur viele Nutzer erreich.
Darüber einspielst, dann eben auch erwischen. Dann geht's aber noch weiter. Du sagst schon nicht nur viele, sondern diese Endnetzwerke bieten dir ja an,
zielgerichtete Werbung zu machen. Also Diätnetzwerke äh sammeln ja über die Besucher so Schätzungen, Einkommensschätzungen, Geschlecht äh äh Schätzungen und alle möglichen ähm.
Herkunft, Business oder nicht.
Genau und wenn du dann sagst, so ich möchte gerne Münchener ähm,
mit einem Jahreseinkommen über äh zweihundertfünfzig K, äh gerne Tageten, dann sagt das Ding, ja okay, klickst du hier, äh kostet halt ein,
Kostet einen Euro mehr oder so?
Dann kannst du die quasi gezielt angreifen. Ich hab das, das genutzt wird, ist glaube ich auch kein großes Geheimnis, ich hatte das auch mal erzählt und jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr, in welcher Folge das war, wo ich von meinem Gespräch
mit einem Cyberkrieger äh berichtet habe. Das ist schon einige Zeit her. Ähm das war aber äh fand ich immer noch so eine der schönsten Folgen, wo ich mal, wo er dann auch so erzählt hat, wie die das,
ebenso machen, beziehungsweise gemacht haben.
Und über diese äh über so Werbedinger, da musst du nicht unbedingt ein Start sein, ne? Wie gesagt, du brauchst brauchst ein paar Euro für ein paar Werbeeinblendungen und dann äh ohnest du halt mal ein paar Leute durch. Daher natürlich die sehr starke Empfehlung am Ende dieses Talks.
Logt Bundespolitik hundertdreiundvierzig Kopfläuse in der Kita.
Okay, die auch nochmal hören. Äh dann.
Also Fazit dieses Talks war natürlich okay. Diese Adnetzwerke sind irgendwie die Pest und ähm das Sicherheitsrisiko, was damit einhergeht, ist enorm. Also installiert zu eurem Schutz doch bitte äh AdBlocker,
Aber wir empfehlen keinen AdBlocker wirklich, weil die sind ja auch die Pest. Stellt sich nämlich raus, dass diese ganzen Adblocker ähm.
Anbieter. In der Regel genauso viele Daten über ihre Nutzer sammeln, wie es die ähm wie es die App Netzwerke selber tun. Das heißt, da hat man eher so eine Wahl zwischen.
Bist du ein Cola war.
Und Cholera.
Von welchen Et-Blockern ist denn das bekannt?
Ja, kommen wir jetzt, wir machen da jetzt mal kurz eine eine Schnittmarke, sonst haben wir ja so einen flinken Übergang.
Ja okay, ähm.
Vielleicht noch dazu, also ich fand äh von den ähm also es war jetzt sagen wir mal für für jemand mit mit einem gewissen technischen Hintergrund war in der Präsentation jetzt nicht viel Neues. War allerdings.
Finde ich A sehr gut platziert auf der Republika, weil da ist einfach mal ein Publikum, ein anderes Publikum, was jetzt nicht so auf dem Kongress äh rumsitzt und ähm ich habe so die Blicke gesehen von so ein paar befreundeten Onlinemagazinbetreibern,
Die so ein bisschen so diesen leeren Blick hatten, als sie irgendwie aus diesem Vortrag rauskamen. Verstehst du? Also es war wirklich.
In Frank, Frank, wie ist da auch darauf hin und sagte so, ja pass auf. Wenn eure Kunden ähm,
Über eure Seite geound werden, über das Ad Netzwerk eurer Seite, dann geht keiner nach Hause und sagt, ah Mist, ich würde über Ad sowieso geohnet, sondern die sagen, Scheiße, ich würde über,
Blick oder.
Domain hierher.
Minuten CH, die waren jetzt zweimal irgendwie offline, äh, weil ihre, so 'ne Schweizer Seite, weil sie da irgendwie die Mywears schleudern waren, ne? Und jetzt kombiniere das mal, das wird passieren.
Kombiniert diese Späße mal mit ähm Kryptotrojanern. Denn die Typen, die Krypto-Trojaner gerade massiv vertreiben, die haben inzwischen locker die Bitcoins zusammen für ein paar Flash-O-Days. Und dann können die,
Also, ne, Flash Zero Day kostet was weiß ich, vielleicht irgendwie so sechzigtausend Euro oder so, sechzigtausend Dollar, ne? Kann man irgendwie äh locker sich mal in Bitcoin kaufen, wenn man ähm ein paar tausend Opfer hatte,
Für seinen Kryptotrojaner.
Und dann hast du nämlich äh eine ganze Menge mehr Opfer, also der Business Case ist jetzt da. Das ist jetzt nur noch eine Frage der Zeit bis sie äh bis sie einfach irgendwo Werbung klicken und dann geht's rund.
Und das war ja auch ein Beispiel. Äh da sieht man sehr schön, dadurch, dass man dann eben auch sagen kann, jetzt steuere ich mal hier äh die billige Masse an und jetzt steuere ich mal die die
Manager mit wichtigen Dateien und auch viel Geld an, dass man dann sozusagen auch die Erpressungszahlungen, die dann gefordert werden von der Ransen, wo er auch entsprechend anpasst, ne? Also so bei den
Privatnutzern, die jetzt irgendwie bei äh einem ganzen Bitcoin niemals mitgehen würden, aber die schmeißen vielleicht die Hälfte oder ein Drittel oder was weiß ich, äh zehn Prozent davon locker ab
weil das ist es ihnen dann noch wert genug,
paar Tage Buchnotizen zu bekommen. Äh kann man dann andererseits bei den äh Leuten, die sozusagen gerade ihren hochbezahlten Job davonschwimmen sehen äh.
Entsprechend höhere Forderungen stellen und auch hier bieten eben diese Netzwerbenetzwerke mit ihrem ganzen Tracking und Profiling einfach ein wunderbares Absprungplattform,
für gezielten Betrug, Erpressung und äh Kriminalität und das ist äh ja, das ist das, was ich in diesem leeren Blick dann auch gesehen habe. Es war.
Ich fand das schon so ein bisschen dramatisch. Also es war schon wirklich so äh die Erkenntnis äh reifte da wirklich so im Hirn und meinte so, ja, harter äh Tobak, oder? Dann ist er, ja, das äh,
das ist nicht schön, weil natürlich, wie wir alle wissen und damit leiten wir im Prinzip jetzt auch auf das nächste Thema zu.
Die Realität ist Online-Magazine verdienen ihr Geld heute eben genau mit dieser Werbung, die Online-Werbung,
Display at Werbung ist das primäre und vorherrschende und wie wir ja auch wissen, hart umkämpfte äh Segment mit dem man eben Geld reinholt und dass er auch nicht zu knapp
mit dem eben der moderne Arm der Medienhäuser heutzutage finanziert wird und auch der von kleineren Startups und Nischenproduktion
und jetzt gerät dieses ganze Haus durch verschiedene Seiten äh unter Feuer,
Das eine haben wir jetzt gerade vorgestellt, dass sozusagen jetzt einfach überhaupt das Ausliefern von Online-Werbung über Dritte äh im Prinzip,
die eigenen Kunden potenziellen Kriminellen äh ausliefert und man hilft eigentlich auch noch ak.
Wenn du beim Ad Netzwerk buchst, bist du ja schon bei den Kriminellen. Also das.
Ich will das mal ja
nehmen wir ruhig diesen einen Schritt noch mit dazu, ja? Weil äh jetzt jetzt jedem, der irgendwie Online-Werbung äh äh Macht betreibt äh und anbietet ähm gleichkriminelle Machenschaften zu unterstellen, finde ich jetzt auch, geht einen Schritt zu weit. Aber,
dieses Tor äh ist auf jeden Fall dann auch geöffnet und fragen sich natürlich jetzt alle,
So und dann kommen die Edblocker da mit rein, ja? Und nehmen sozusagen diese Werbung auch noch weg. Ähm wieder eine potenzielle Einbuße äh des ganzen Kuchens,
fragen sich natürlich alle, was, was sollen sie jetzt tun.
Also die Diätnetzwerke sind vielleicht so, das sollte man nochmal kurz zusammenfassen, die Entennetzwerke sind deshalb ein Problem, weil sie eingebunden werden in die Seiten,
die du eigentlich besuchst. Das heißt, du gehst auf was weiß ich, Süddeutsche DE und dann denn oder Spiegel oder sonst was und dein Browser macht noch
Verbindung zu fuffzehn anderen Domains, um sich diese ganze Werbung zu laden und Bescheid zu sagen, dass sie sich diese Seite gerade anschaut und diese, das heißt egal wo du hingehst für das Ad Netzwerk bist du einfach immer nur irgendwo anders
und das ist für die
ein kleiner Parameter, der mitgeliefert wird, wenn du diese Seite besuchst, das heißt die verfolgen dich durch das Netz und machen Profil über dich und ballern dich dann entsprechend mit der Werbung zu. Die äh die ähm stöhnen aber natürlich gerade, weil
so so
und Facebook denen eigentlich das komplett kaputt machen, ne? Also dieses irgendwie äh diese kleineren Werbedinger äh haben ja schon ordentlich zu kämpfen.
Ähm die Verlage, die Seiten, die Werbung ähm die kostenlose Inhalte ins Netz stellen,
Für die ist das einfach mal das einzige sinnvolle oder das einzige noch nicht einmal vernünftig funktionierende Geschäftsmodell,
ist es diese einfach Edflächen zu vermieten und zu gucken, was dir am Ende des Monats überweisen. Das ist das einzige, was funktioniert für die,
Ähm die fangen dann an mit ihren Digital-Abos, äh die fangen an mit ihr, aber damit kriegen die niemals diese Dinger finanziert. Ähm Spiegel online,
ähm oder Süddeutsche DE. Das sind riesige Angebote mit nennenswerten Redaktionen,
die wollen alle ihr Geld bekommen, die da schreiben, die ganze Infrastruktur um den Scheiß am Laufen zu halten, muss irgendwie bezahlt werden und es ist mir,
Überhaupt ein Rätsel, ob die das überhaupt werbefinanziert hinkriegen. Und es kriegen sie offenbar auch nicht. Und dann,
Wenn dann mal irgendwie zwanzig Prozent oder zehn Prozent der Nutzer so einen AdBlocker nutzen, dann kriegen die richtig Schweißperlen auf der Stirn. Da haben wir ja jetzt gerade diese ganzen Kriegereien zwischen den Edblocker Blockern.
Den AdBlocker Blocker entblockern.
Also Seiten, die hingegangen sind und gesagt haben, also allen voran Bild DE, die gesagt haben, okay, du hast einen Werbeblock hat, dann kannst du unsere Inhalte nicht sehen,
oder du buchst hier irgendwie so ein Digitalpaket für fünf Euro.
Prinzipiell ja gar nicht so eine blöde Idee zu sagen, entweder du guckst dir das mit Werbung an oder du bezahlst, dass du keine Werbung hast und dann bezahlst du ungefähr so viel, wie wir an dir verdienen würden. Also irgendwo muss es ja nun mal auch,
Ne, denn es wollen ja viele immer nicht hören. Ähm aber irgendwo muss der Scheiß ja auch bezahlt werden, damit die, die den ganzen Tag zu Hause sitzen, sich das auch angucken können. Ja.
Nur dass die Abo-Preise natürlich deutlich höher und die Einzelbezahlpreise.
Keiner bereit zu zahlen.
Genau, also es genau.
Jetzt dann, so lange ging's ja weiter, dann sind äh dann sind also Leute hingegangen, also dann gab's AdBlocker Blocker, ja? Bild DE finde ich gerade einen super Service, wenn ich aus Versehen auf Bild DE Klicke stehe, können sie nicht angucken. Super, wunderbar, finde ich in Ordnung. Oder ich muss bezahlen, kimme ich natürlich im Traum nicht auf die Idee.
Und dann gab es AdBlocker.
AdBlocker, Blocker, Endblocker, äh die gesagt haben, den Teil des Javaskets, der checkt, ob die Werbung geblockt wird, den bloggen wir.
Und geben dem oder geben dem einen, geben dem den Eindruck, wir würden die Werbung angucken, sodass wir die Inhalte trotzdem sehen können und die Werbung trotzdem nicht einblenden.
Und die wurden dann halt mit Klagen überzogen und die klagen sich da gegenseitig in Grot und Bohnen, Spiegel Online klagt gerade gegen iO mit ihrem Black äh AdBlock Plus und.
Ähm.
Spiegel hat äh irgendwie im Rahmen eines Artikels so transparent unter anderem wir klaren gegen iOG MBH, die die einen AdBlocker vertreiben. Ähm.
Bild wiederum klagt gegen iO, weil sie diesen AdBlocker Blocker entblocker haben,
Also die verklagen sich da alle gerade gegenseitig, ja? Und in der Mitte ist der Nutzer der
Die Wahl hat zwischen okay, ich gehe entweder hin und lasse mich, setze mich diesen ganzen Geblinker aus und den den Sicherheitsrisiken, die damit einhergehen,
Oder ich setze mich dem Risiko, aus dem ich die AdBlocker aussetzen, denn die sind ja im Namen äh im Falle von iO hingegangen und haben gesagt, oh krass, wir haben jetzt hier auch irgendwie eine ein oder zweistellige,
äh äh Millionen an Nutzern.
Dann lass uns doch mal überlegen, wie wir daraus Geld machen. Und das Erste, was sie offenbar gemacht haben, war zu sagen, na ja,
Mit den Nutzern fressen wir anderen ja gerade signifikant Kapital weg. Lass uns denen doch mal Möglichkeiten anbieten, das zurückzubekommen. Und das war bei AdBlock Plus dann die äh akzeptable Werbung,
Dass sie den Nutzern gesagt haben, hey ja und so, ne, ein bisschen Werbung muss ja sein und so. Und wir machen jetzt so nicht so aufdringliche Werbung, kannst du freischalten. Ist haben wir mal die Folge für dich gemacht? Dann gibt's quasi Lücken in unserem.
In unserem AdBlocker.
Und wo diese Lücken sind und welche auf welcher Seite und welche Werbung sie durchlassen das äh wird dadurch bestimmt wer bei uns bezahlt. Das heißt, sie haben im Prinzip,
Die Werbeflächen, die ja nun mal anderen gehörten, ob man das jetzt gut findet oder nicht, ja,
Süddeutsche DE oder sowas ist hingegangen, hat gesagt, dieses Werbenetzwerk kriegt folgende Anzahl von Pixel auf unserer Seite, um da seinen Scheiß einzuspielen und uns am Ende Geld dafür zu geben. Und iO ist quasi hingegangen und hat gesagt, das blenden wir aus,
Es sei denn, ihr bezahlt auch nochmal an uns. Das äh kann man jetzt einmal betrachten als.
Handeln im Interesse des Nutzers? Nicht so aufdringliche Werbung.
Und den anderen ja doch noch eine Möglichkeit zu geben, trotz Adblocker äh eine Werbeeinblendung zu erzielen. Das kann man auch einfach mal als ein ziemlich asoziales Geschäftsmodell äh bezeichnen, wo sie nämlich ihre Nutzer wiederum weiter verkaufen.
Und äh insofern in diesem Bereich gibt es jetzt nicht wirklich viele gute und.
Dafür aber viele Ratlose, weil wir irgendwie diesen Mist eben auch finanziert bekommen möchten. Und da hat sich jetzt eine neue.
Ähm interessante Perspektive gegeben, ergeben, die ich in ihrer, in ihrer Idee ziemlich smart finde,
AdBlock Plus, ich glaube, wir hatten ausführlich zusammengefasst, dass das dass die Firma dahinter jetzt nicht unbedingt eine der sympathischsten und rein gutes gütlichsten Firmen ist,
Geht hin und kooperiert mit Fletter. Und deren Ziel ist quasi sowas wie wir blocken dir die Werbung raus.
Aber diejenigen, die sich gleichzeitig für Fletter plus registriert haben, kriegen dann für die ausgeblendete Werbung einen deiner Fletter.
Deiner Fletterklicks. Ja, das heißt, du hast werbefreie ähm Werbefreies Netz.
Mit mit einem guten Adblocker, der dich hoffentlich nicht vollständig verrät und,
Gleichzeitig gibst du ein Budget an von ich denke mal gerechtfertigt, wer irgendwas zwischen zwischen fünf und fünfzehn Euro oder sowas würde ich jetzt so sehen. Ähm,
und das wird entsprechend deiner Seitenbesuche auf Seiten, die wo du wo die Werbung weggebloggt wurde und du gleichzeitig bei die gleichzeitig Beitrag Fluss sind, verteilt.
Fletter und AdBlock Plus ziehen aber zehn Prozent der Kohle ein. Was übrigens ähm bei Flatters glaube ich schon immer so war.
Und was der schlechteste Deal ist, den man überhaupt äh auf dieser Erde bekommt, ne? Also äh niemand anders nimmt hier, nimmt dir zehn Prozent deines Geldes weg, ne? Kannst du mit, kannst du wahrscheinlich eine eine
Überweisung machen, eine Seepaar Überweisung von Sydney, da werden dir keine zehn Prozent draufgeschlagen, aber okay.
Also bei bei PayPal wird man auch eine ganze Menge los. Kannst du aber jetzt gerade nicht quantifizieren.
Ein Euro oder so was für eine für 'ne Überweisung. Ich hab letztens mal vierunddreißig Euro über Fletter, über Paper jemanden geschickt und hat ein Euro gekostet. Fand ich krass. Äh bei Fletter hätte es aber eben drei Euro vierzig gekostet, ne?
Mhm.
Okay, also mit denen schließen sie das jetzt zusammen.
Also.
Lässt sich so direkt nicht vergleichen, weil das ja sozusagen im Monats äh Pauschale über alle Transaktionen ist, aber du hast schon recht. Der äh Beitrag ist hoch, hat übrigens auch Fletter selber immer gesagt, dass sie den hoch finden,
ja? Hat allerdings äh auch,
auch nicht dazu geführt, dass dass der Laden sich dadurch wirklich äh alleine finanziert, hat sie aber vielleicht etwas länger getragen, als es eben noch einem geringeren Betrag gewesen wäre und,
Sie meinten auch immer, das nehme ich ihnen auch ab. Das in dem Moment, wo halt,
der Motor rund läuft, was er nie lief, äh sieht diesen Betrag ja immer noch senken könnten, aber und auch wollten, aber dass sie dazu eben noch zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht in der Lage sind.
Genau, Fletter, also die sehr coole Idee des Micropaymens, die lange Zeit.
Ganz gut mal funktioniert hat.
Die aber auch in sich selber so eine Zentralisierungstendenz hat, ne? Also ähm bei den wenigen über Fletter, signifikant, äh, erfolgreichen, kommt dann doch ein ganz guter Betrag an,
Und bei vielen anderen äh ballern dann irgendwie so zwei, drei Euro Beträge durch die Gegend, die sie am Ende lieber benutzen, um den um sie einfach weiter zu verflettern äh als.
Äh als sie sich irgendwie auszahlen zu lassen. Äh noch dazu gibt's dann eben dieses, dadurch, dass sie eben immer zehn Prozent nehmen und solange du das Geld da einmal hin und her fletterst,
und das Geld da drin bleibt, äh, wird es quasi wird es für Geld sie einfach nutzen, du kannst innerhalb von Flettergeld so lange hin und her schießen, bis es auf ein Cent runter ist.
Genau, das ist das das ich nenne das Multiple Taxation äh Problem, was halt eine Folge ihres äh Basismodells ist, wie es eben läuft,
Offenbar ist das aller sorgt sorgt das Geld, was darüber dann versickert theoretisch ähm sind keine nennenswerten Beträge innerhalb des Flattersystems.
Zehn Prozent halt, ne? Aber okay, ist ja eg.
Nein, nicht relativ zu dem Betrag, sondern ins insgesamt, was sozusagen darüber äh tatsächlich verloren geht.
Kann man's auch weglassen. Also dieses System was ich trotzdem für eine bisher die beste Idee halte.
Hat auf jeden Fall noch Verbesserungspotential, eine Menge.
Dieses System hat es also nicht geschafft, sich nennenswert zu etablieren. Ähm.
Warum?
Ist ja gut, kann ich vielleicht so und die haben also das Problem äh sich irgendwie.
Die haben einfach irgendwann kein Wachstum mehr gehabt, sondern die schrumpfen inzwischen. Die haben richtig
massive massiven Rückgang an Nutzerzahlen und auch massiven Rückgang an dem Umsatz, das heißt die hatten, da haben natürlich einen Partner gesucht, der ihnen richtig krasse, neue, potenzielle äh Nutzerzahlen äh bieten kann.
Und diese Adblocker IO haben natürlich nach einem Partner gesucht, der ihn,
ja auch mal eine eine geilere Userstory oder sowas gibt, ne, mit diesen okay Werbung ist Kacke und äh wir verkaufen lass uns deine Daten verkaufen.
Das äh trägt halt auch nicht besonders.
Trägt halt auch nicht besonders weit und da ist eben jetzt rausgekommen äh Fletter,
plus das jetzt dann irgendwann vorgestellt werden soll. Du hast also irgendwie diese Facebookwelt in der dieses verteilte Netz auch immer mehr passé ist.
Der Journalismus ist immer mehr im Arsch, der schrumpft gerade kaputt, ne? Das ist einfach äh wir haben bald keinen keinen ordentlichen Journalismus mehr. Ähm.
Keiner verdient mehr wirklich Geld und Werbung ist irgendwie die einzige Möglichkeit. Oder,
Du äh gönnst dir das eben halt, wie, wie, was weiß ich, wie wir jetzt hier zu sagen, okay
Wir machen das mehr oder weniger aus äh Idealismus und weil wir an anderer Stelle genug Geld verdienen
um uns das leisten zu können. Wenn ich jetzt hier bei Logbruch Netzpolitik mal irgendwie halbwegs zugrunde legen würde, dass ich das für mich finanziell lohnt, dann würde ich damit nächste Woche aufhören.
Ähm und aber genau solche Idealisten aus so einer Idealistenperspektive.
Die ganze Zeit rumzunüllen, geht mir eben auch nicht weit genug, ja? Also da möchte ich schon irgendwie anerkennen, dass bestimmte Dinge eben äh am Ende bezahlt werden müssen und diese Werbung stinkt eben und jetzt mit Fletter Plus, halte ich das für eine ziemlich geile
Idee, die aber natürlich trotzdem so ein bisschen.
Erpresserstyle ist, ne? Also die die helfen halt den.
Ein anderes Geschäftsmodell über, ja? Und sagen, pass auf, wir haben einfach mal zehn Prozent dieses dieser Werbescheiße geblockt.
Und äh wir werden jetzt werben dafür, dass es noch viel mehr Leute machen und ihr könnt die Gelegenheit bekommen, euch von uns äh auszahlen zu lassen, dafür, dass unsere Nutzer eure Seite besucht haben,
Manchmal funktionieren Geschäftsmodelle aber eben auch nicht anders als dass du Menschen erpresst.
Wo siehst du jetzt den Erpressungsfaktor bei.
Die Alternative, die Alternative ist, du wirst nicht deren Kunde und verzichtest auf die zehn Prozent Einnahmen. Du kannst, du hast doch, du, du.
Pullisher meinst du jetzt?
Du hast dich als Publisher entschieden, dass du über Werbung dein Angebot finanzierst. Und die gehen hin und sagen, wir nehmen dir, was weiß ich so und so viel Prozent der Werbeeinblendungen weg. Die spürst du direkt in deinem Budget.
Aber hey, wir geben dir eine Möglichkeit auf andere Weise an dieses Geld zu kommen. Das ist eine ziemlich also.
Für ist eine Zwickmühle oder eine eine äh eine erpresserische Situation in die man den anderen da bringt, weil er eben nicht mehr die freie Wahl hat, das so zu machen, wie er es gerne möchte.
Wie gesagt, der hatte, der hat am Anfang sich eh für den für das Falsche entschieden, aber diese Publisher haben eben auch keine Optionen. Du kannst doch heute keinen Publisher einen Vorwurf machen, dass er diese Werbenetzwerke nutzt, weil das ist nun mal die einzige Möglichkeit,
Kann das eben auch sein lassen? Oder die suchen sich alle einen anderen Job und machen das nur noch als Hobby. Fände ich auch nicht schlecht, aber äh ist eben schwierig.
Ja, kann ja natürlich sein, dass der jetzt ein neuer Weg auch entsteht.
Genau und das Problem, was ich immer gesehen habe bei sowas war, dass du irgendwo tracken musst.
Wer welche Seiten besucht hat,
war nie das Problem oder hat hat nie jemanden gestört bei diesen Endnetzwerken, die dich eh auf jede scheiß Internetseite, die du besuchst, verfolgen. Da hat sich nie jemand Gedanken darüber gemacht, aber bei Fletter war natürlich und bei den Like-Buttons und so, da waren dann natürlich immer das Theater groß,
Ja, Flettertracking, Flattertracking. Klar, Fletter weiß, welche Seite du besucht hast, Fletterweiß ähm welche du dabei geflettert hast.
Ähm aber Vetter hat halt einfach nicht die Kohle, um die Daten mal vernünftig zu analysieren und hat wahrscheinlich auch irgendwelche AGBs, die ihnen das, in denen sie zu sichern, das nicht zu tun.
Wenn die aber jetzt Autofletter machen, dann müssen sie natürlich irgendwie feststellen, dass du gerade auf dieser Seite warst, welcher Monat es gerade ist und das eben einen Seitenbesuch aus deinem
Fletterbudget diesem Kunden äh abgebucht wird. Das heißt, da haben sie nochmal äh datenschutzrechtlich ähm Herausforderungen
wenn sie das so umsetzen.
Da die IO aber seit jeher offenbar Nutzerdaten auswertet, äh haben die wahrscheinlich auch schon die Anwälte, um sich darüber Gedanken zu machen.
Ich denke, das Interesse von Fletter ist an der Stelle eben nicht äh nicht mehr als nötig äh zu machen, weil alles, was sie ja brauchen ist die Information. Also einerseits brauchen sie irgendeine Horistik, die lokal abläuft im Browser,
ist jetzt dieser Artikel bereits durch diese Nutzung, die hier vorliegt, äh fletterwürdig, es gibt äh soweit ich in die Planung ähm da äh Einblick habe nehmen können,
so den Ansatz, na ja, Verweildauer auf der Seite sozusagen so typische Benutzung, also so geöffnet das Fenster, was sofort wieder geschlossen wird, soll in dem Fall zum Beispiel nicht,
Zu einem Fletterklick führen und muss natürlich auch in irgendeiner Form herausfinden, ist denn diese Seite überhaupt.
Die hier gerade betrachtet wird, ist diese Domän oder dieser dieser Bereich einer Domäne,
sozusagen überhaupt registriert, liegt dafür etwas klickbares vor, ist derjenige, der hier publiziert, auch bei uns registriert. Auch diese Information muss natürlich abgeglichen werden,
aber sich jetzt viel über die technischen Details mit Hash Values und Pipapo äh unterhalten. Das muss man jetzt am Ende mal sehen, wie das äh tatsächlich umgesetzt wird und wir auch die Eigendarstellung ist.
Die Truppe um Fletter ist auf jeden Fall dafür bekannt, dass sie sozusagen jetzt nicht unbedingt besondere äh Fans von sehr viel Privacy bei Laven sind.
Ja auf jeden Fall, also es aber ich glaube da wird's die werden auch wieder verklagt werden.
Von nimmst den Werbenetzbetreibern, weil die sagen, ey, ich meine, das ist eine Sache, unsere Werbung auszublenden, aber ist eine andere, das auch nochmal irgendwie kommerziell zu machen und den Leuten, die wir, ja, also das wird,
Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie sie's technisch umsetzen. Ähm das wird auf jeden Fall mal ganz interessant und ähm.
Wird wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen dauern. Ähm es wird vermutlich, also was man ja auch noch dazu sagen muss,
Gibt da noch eine zweite technische Herausforderung. Das Ganze basiert im ersten Schritt auf jeden Fall auf Browser Extensions,
sowie AdBlock Plus ja eine.
Die erste war der erste Rollout wird aber noch nicht im Edclub Plus selber stattfinden. Mhm. Sondern es wird zurzeit erstmal eine separate äh Extension geben, Fletter Plus,
weil sie diesen Schritt in Europus und damit in diese diesem Zeitpunkt machen wollen, wo sie sich total sich.
Mist funktioniert, ja?
Bleibt aber natürlich am Ende auch noch ein äh Browserextension. Es at Block Plus ist auf Mobilnetzen, auf dem iPhone et cetera in der Form überhaupt gar nicht vorhanden
weil äh diese Funktionalität, die eine Browser-Extension hat, nicht vergleichbar ist mit der Funktionalität, die so einen Content Blocker unter iOS zum Beispiel hat,
Also Content-Blogger und der iOS ist nicht im selben äh in der selben Form Running Code,
sondern es handelt sich hierbei im Prinzip nichts anderes als um äh eine eine Blacklist, die man äh dort kodiert, die halt sehr schnell vom Browser durchsucht werden kann. Aber äh,
es wird nicht mit jedem Ladeversuch einer Seite
Code gestartet, der dann eben sehr intelligent äh mit den Inhalten und Zeiten und sonstigen Parametern arbeiten kann
Ich habe mir andeuten lassen, wie sie da Gedenken diese Situation auf mobil zu lösen, aber äh weiß nicht, so richtig klar geworden ist mir das nicht,
ähm wie sie gedenken, auch diese Nutzung mit abzufangen. Also das ist natürlich ein Problem, dass ihr hier eigentlich auf alte Technologie setzen. Und von daher bin ich auch sehr gespannt, wie die technische Umsetzung,
sein wird. Es könnte allerdings dazu führen, dass wieder mehr Leute auf Fletter überhaupt aufmerksam werden, muss man sehen.
So ähm da müssen wir natürlich noch zur Zusammenfassung sagen ähm,
Also IO GmbH sicherlich nicht unbedingt einer von den Besten. Da gab's vor einigen Jahren äh eben diese Recherchen von
einem Bloggernamen Sascha Pallenberg, der da sehr weit hinterher war, was ja iO alles macht und so und da sehr viel Gas gegeben hat und diese Firma seither so auf seinem KiKa hat
der hat noch eine,
zweite Gruppe an Menschen auf dem KIKA und das sind die Leute, die sich früh mehr oder weniger dem Netzfeminismus verbunden fühlen und dieses Fletterplus wurde jetzt äh,
dem großen Peter Sunde und einer,
Dame vorgestellt, die diesen Netzfeministinnen zugerechnet wird. Und wenn du jetzt Netzfeministin und iO GmbH auf einer Bühne hast, äh dann ist das natürlich für Sascha Palenberg,
ein Thema wo er sich sehr mit auseinandersetzt und er hat da so ein bisschen also er hat ist da sehr eifrig bei diesen Auseinandersetzungen so ein bisschen das Problem, dass seine Artikel immer ein bisschen zu lang werden.
Und er dann auch immer ja leider es ihm nicht gelingt,
so auf so atominem Geschichten zu verzichten und dann immer so, dass die ganz große Verschwörung aufspinnt so auch in in diesem Falle, wo das wo er dann noch,
den Filz in der Republika aufgedeckt hat und und hier auf dem Xing-Profil und äh ähm ja ähm,
der äh versteigert sich da manchmal in so ein paar Sachen und ist dann sehr, sehr wortgewaltig. Äh nichtsdestotrotz denke ich, sollte man diesen ähm diesen Punkt, wie eben, was das Modell von von Werbeblockern ist,
da durchaus auch nochmal eben kritisch hinterfragen und sich eben überlegen,
Welche Rolle spielt in dieser Welt jetzt hier eben dieser Konsument, ne? Und weil viel mehr bist du da gar nicht. Ob da jetzt der, ob da jetzt der Werbeblocker äh um dich kämpft, der,
Fletterdienst, der zehn Prozent nimmt oder eben das Netzwerk sind alles irgendwie.
Nicht die schönsten Lösungen, aber bessere haben wir eben nicht. Und jetzt muss man eben gucken, wie wollen wir denn in Zukunft ähm.
Uns mit diesen mit diesem Internet da äh zufrieden geben. Wie soll das, wer soll das bezahlen,
Was äh ich glaube dieser äh Sascha auch so ein bisschen außer Augen lässt, ist eben das,
der diese auch diese große Bloggerkonferenz Republika oder so, ne? Das ist doch keine Bloggerkonferenz, weil wer bloggt denn heute noch? Das sind ja auch nur noch sehr wenige, äh die sich das erlauben können,
unter anderem er, hm, weil er Produktblogs macht mit Affiliate-Links. Ja,
Gut, kann man jetzt auch sich irgendwie drüber aufregen oder man kann eben sagen, ist doch schön, wenn er das so macht.
Alle ringen um äh Businessmodelle am Ende ähm muss man halt auch sehen, was was wird von Leuten äh auch akzeptiert.
Grad bei denen sind zehn Prozent von äh Fletter, frage ich mich halt auch, ob sozusagen.
Ob sozusagen hier nicht noch sehr viel mehr Luft drin ist. Also ist das Modell sozusagen auf einmal attraktiver, wenn man auf fünf Prozent ist, äh äh wird es irgendwann sozusagen eine goldene Lösung, wenn es auf einen Prozent äh äh runter ist? Schwer zu sagen.
Nehme das jetzt nur als Beispiel dafür, dass dass jetzt auch nicht nur die Guten sind. Ne, also die haben auch,
am Ende wirst du und da das ich denke da gerade an.
In mehreren Kontexten Duana, am Ende wirst du eben kein größeres Problem gelöst kriegen,
ohne dass irgendwo jemand sitzt, der davon auch profitiert.
Finanziell, egal was du machst, ja, wenn du jetzt irgendwie ein, ne, du bezahlst die gerade die Bezahlproblematik, die löst doch keiner, die Bezahlproblematik und geht dabei leer aus,
sei es, sag sei es die Erfindung von Bitcoin, die jetzt am Ende
ja auch im im Rahmen dieser großen äh Mining-Konglumerate mehr oder weniger äh sich gesammelt hat
Insofern, ja, Kommerz ist eben auch Teil dieser Welt und da kann man eben gucken, wer ein lauteres Angebot macht oder ein ein schönes Angebot der Gesellschaft bietet, äh wo alle äh Interessen berücksichtigt werden,
und wer in diesem, wer da irgendwie in dieser Welt falsch spielt, aber ich finde, diese äh diese komplette Antihaltung ähm gegen eine Republika, die Gesellschaft
und Wirtschaft und Zukunft in einer Konferenz widerspiegelt, ähm ist dann eben auch wirklich einfach ein bisschen.
Ein bisschen zu kurz gedacht. Es gibt wenige Menschen äh und,
Die den Luxus genießen, ihre Polizistische Tätigkeit irgendwie finanziell unabhängig machen zu können ähm wir gehören dazu, Netzpolitik ORG gehören dazu ähm und dass das irgendwie nicht die ähm,
Das neue Modell für die Welt sein kann ist eben auch irgendwie leider inzwischen die traurige Erkenntnis geworden.
Wir sind nicht die Vorreitern, irgendwann werden's alle so machen.
Können sie gerne machen.
Aber da gibt's aber auch kein Geld mehr.
Ja nicht so, als würden wir.
Es ist ja nicht so, als würden wir ähm keine äh keine Spenden für unsere Projekte bekommen. Aber es äh reicht eben auch nicht, um damit großartig weit.
Springen zu können. Den Anspruch haben wir aber auch.
Geld muss auch genommen werden dürfen, ob äh äh ein ein Tarif, der genommen wird, angemessen ist oder nicht, entscheidet letzten Endes derjenige, der äh sich äh,
für ein oder gegen einen Dienst entscheidet, ja,
Margen können auch gerechtfertigt sein, wenn die Dienstleistung angemessen ist, wenn die wenn man das äh äh für wünschenswert hält, was damit eben bewirkt wird. Und wenn nicht, muss man sich eben über diesen Tarif Gedanken machen. Schwieriger wird's halt,
wenn man eigentlich gar nicht mehr der Kunde ist, ja? Und äh das ist ja.
Sehr viel häufiger ein Problem wie zum Beispiel.
In dem Moment, wo man sozusagen Opfer eines Werbenetzwerks wird, weil man da einfach sozusagen nur noch das Produkt ist, so.
Muss man mal schauen. Also Fletter Plus, ich bin.
Bei Fletter, bei Amazon.
Nein, ich bin,
Versuche gerade äh ich denke da natürlich jetzt auch sehr viel drüber nach, weil ich habe ja nun wirklich diesen Weg von von Fletter sehr eng äh begleitet. Ich äh ich kenne die Truppe äh sehr gut, ich kenne auch ihre ihre Motivation und ihre Argumentation äh sehr gut.
Und ähm find's auch toll, dass sie eigentlich auch immer noch äh der Meinung sind, dass ihr Modell so gut ist, wie ich's auch äh selber finde
Es wäre schön gewesen, wenn sie sozusagen schon frühzeitig äh davon so hätten profitieren können, dass sie auch gesagt haben, okay, jetzt gehen wir auch von diesen zehn Prozent runter,
das fand so nicht statt. Blätterplus ist ja auch ein Versuch der Problematik der Plattform,
zu entgehen, weil ein Teil des Misserfolgs von Fletter, den es sicherlich gab, äh hat eben auch einfach was mit den geschlossenen Systemen zu tun, allen voran Apple,
Ich denke, dass äh das Untersagen von von Fletter im äh App Store Ökosystem von iOS ähm,
eine der ganz großen Spaßbremsen war,
aber natürlich auch überhaupt so geschlossene Systeme wie äh Facebook et cetera, wo du eben mit so einer Open Webide wie äh einem Fletterplatten halt überhaupt
gar nicht äh reinkommen kannst
Deswegen äh ist jetzt quasi Fletter Plus auch der Versuch das Ganze von der anderen Seite anzugehen und in der letzten Stelle, wo man noch eingreifen kann, nämlich in diesen Browser Extensions sich äh reinzumappen und dadurch äh im Prinzip Zugang zu jeder URL zu erhalten, ohne dass die irgendwie groß angemeldet werden muss.
Finde ich auch nicht uncool,
Also man muss sich ja irgendwann auch wenn du jahrelang dir irgendwie über freies offenes Web und so weiter Gedanken machst, dann musst du eben auch irgendwann mal überlegen gegen wen du hier gerade spielst und wie die spielen.
Und da muss man sich eben überlegen, wie man da irgendwo einen Fuß in die Tür kriegt. Anders funktioniert Wirtschaft eben auch nicht. Kann man jetzt gut finden oder schlecht finden.
Aber so ist es halt nun mal.
Kommen wir zu etwas vollkommen anderem.
Ja, die Panama Papers. Heute ist übrigens heute wäre der Tag, wo sie dann
Nee, ist nun doch, heute ist der neunte. Heute wird, wird dann irgendwann, wird das alles wird ein Teil dieser Auszüge der Information gedampft und vor ein paar Tagen wurde dann von der, ich denke, in der Süddeutschen Zeitung, wenn ich das richtig erinnere,
Das Manifest von John Doe veröffentlicht und das fand ich ein wirklich äh
beeindruckenden Text, den man mal äh so gelesen haben sollte. Ich werde da jetzt mal so ein bisschen Ausschnitte von ähm.
Von zitieren
Also er fängt damit an und sagt, okay, die Ungleichheit der Einkommen und die Kluft zwischen arm und reich ist eines der wichtigsten Themen unserer Zeit. Das ist klar, man sieht im Prinzip, dass du innerhalb von äh Staaten aber auch äh zwischen den Staaten eine
Einen Abstand zwischen Armut Reichers und der wird immer größer.
Oma hat sich gefragt oder man fragte sich immer, ja wie kann das denn sein und so, ne? Wir haben noch irgendwie so schöne Demokratie und so. Wie kommt das denn, dass diese Kluft immer größer wird? Und er sagt, in den Panamper Papers,
ist die Antwort darauf nun offensichtlich geworden, umfassende, alltägliche Korruption.
Und dann untersagt er Mossak von Zirka hat eben viel mehr gemacht als nur existierende äh Schlupflöcher,
ausnutzt, auszunutzen oder Hilfe Beihilfe dazu zu leisten, sondern sie hat ihren Einfluss genutzt, weltweit Gesetze,
zu diktieren und zu umgehen, um so über Jahrzehnte hinweg die Interessen von Kriminellen durchzusetzen. Das heißt, also er meint damit, sie haben,
darauf geachtet, dass die Gesetze ihnen weiterhin die diese Schlupflöcher bieten.
Ähm den die eigentliche, das eigentliche Ziel des Gesetzes zu umgehen. Jurist,
Juristerei ist ja auch viel einfach nur oft darauf rumzureiten, wie es irgendwo geschrieben steht und da kommt's eben auch teilweise mal auf einen Nebensatz an.
Und jetzt sagt er, jetzt haben wir jahrelang das freundlich das Fehlverhalten der Reichen und Mächtigen sorgsam ausgeklammert, weil wir irgendwie nicht äh uns der stumpfen Kapitalismus äh Kritik schuldig machen wollten.
Aber jetzt geht es endlich mal um den Kern der Sache. Ähm nämlich darum, wie hier äh,
mit der Gesellschaft und ihren Regeln umgegangen wird, dann sagte ich, er arbeitet nicht für eine Regierung oder irgendein Geheimdienst, hat das nie getan,
Weder als direkter Angestellter noch in Auftrag.
Und sagt aber, okay, das äh International Consortium Investition und seine Partner, Partnermedien haben vollkommen zurecht gesagt, dass sie diese Dokumente nicht weitergeben,
auch nicht an Strafverfolgungsbehörden. Er sagt, er ist bereit, mit Behörden zusammenzuarbeiten.
Im Rahmen seiner Möglichkeiten und er sagt das, was in diesen Dokumenten drin ist.
Reicht für tausende Strafverfahren, die die Strafverfolgungsbehörden weltweit über Jahre, wenn nicht Jahrzehnte beschäftigen werden.
Aber er hat ja mit angesehen, was mit Whisleblowern und Aktivisten in den USA und Europa geschehen ist, wie ihr Leben zerstört wurde, nachdem sie die Vorgänge öffentlich gemacht haben, die offensichtlich kriminell waren,
Edwards Norden sitzt ins Moskaufest im Exil. Die Obama-Regierung auf Grundlage des,
Weil die Obama-Regierung auf Grundlage des Anti-Spionagesgesetzes Haftbefehl gegen ihn erlassen hat,
Er findet, man sollte Edward Snowden für seine NSA-Enthüllung als Helden feiern und ihm Preise verlangen, aber ihn nicht bestrafen. Bradley Birkenfeld bekam von der US-Steuerbehörde Millionen für seine Informationen über die Schweizer Bank UBS
wurde dennoch vom US-Justizministerium verurteilt. An Twen Deltour wird
momentan in Luxemburg der Prozess gemacht, weil er Journalisten, Journalisten, Informationen zur Verfügung gestellt hat, die offenlegten, wie das Land mit enormen Steuervergünstigungen, internationale Firmen angelockt hat
Und damit letztlich seine europäischen Nachbarländer um Milliarden an Steuergeldern gebracht hat.
Er kritisiert ganz klar, was mit Leuten wie ihm passiert. Die äh so eine Kanzlei äh offenlegen, die tausende von Steuerhinterziehern offenlegen,
Während Moslec Francica in der Öffentlichkeit so getan hat, als hätten sie von all dem nichts gewusst. Ähm aber seine Dokumente eben auch zeigen, dass sie genau informiert waren und vorsätzlich gegen Gesetze verstoßen haben.
Zum Beispiel äh weist er aus, dass Jürgen Mosak vor einem Bundesgericht in Nevada ein Main-Eid geschworen hat.
Und dass seine IT-Abteilung danach versucht hat, in diesem Verfahren Beweise verschwinden zu lassen
Ja, das sind ja Dinge, ich meine, das sind wirklich mal üble Sachen, ja? Meiner schwören äh Beweismittel, äh verschwinden zu lassen. Das sind Dinge, die gehören vor Gericht, diese ganze Steuerhinterziehergeschichte natürlich auch, aber am Ende muss er jetzt
mehr oder weniger um sein ähm,
Leben führe ich und fordert jetzt, wenn jetzt auf politischen Gipfeltreffen das hohe Lied staatlicher Transparenz gesungen wird, dann ist das eine Sache, aber diesen Worten sollen dann eben auch mal,
Ähm Taten folgen. Ähm.
Und erschließt dann damit, dass er sagt, die Medien haben versagt,
Viele Fernsehanstalten sind nur noch lächerliche Abziehbilder ihrer selbst und unter Milliardären scheint es neuerdings in Mode gekommen zu sein, Zeitungen aufzukaufen, um so eine,
ernsthafte Berichterstattung über die reichen und superreichen zu verhindern. Seriösen, investigativ Journalisten fehlt es dagegen an finanziellen Mählen,
Aber an erster Stelle haben Anwälte versagt, eine Demokratie braucht verantwortungsvolle Individuen, die das Gesetz verstehen und es wahren, nicht solche, die verstehen, es auszunutzen.
Und dann schließt er mit äh mit.
Am Ende Historiker wissen, dass Besteuerung und ungleiche Machtverhältnisse in der Vergangenheit bereits Revolutionen ausgelöst haben. Damals war militärische Macht notwendig, um die Menschen zu unterdrücken,
Während es heute genauso effektiv oder noch effektiver ist, die Menschen vom Zugang zu Informationen abzuschneiden.
Auch weil das im verborgenen geschieht. Aber wir leben in einer Zeit günstiger, grenzenloser Datenspeicher und schneller Internetverbindungen, die nationale Grenzen überschreiten,
Es sieht also sehr danach aus, dass die nächste Revolution digital sein wird. Vielleicht hat sie aber auch schon begonnen.
Das fand ich mal ein sehr ähm wichtigen Text.
Weshalb ich den jetzt hier auch einfach mal so mehr oder weniger mit einigen Lücken und äh vollständig zitiere,
wo er mal so ein bisschen wieder den Blick auf das etwas Wesentlicheres richtet als das Hetzen von einem liegt zum anderen und von der einen Demo zur anderen.
Ja, ist bemerkenswert. Man fragt sich äh, ob hier äh auch jemand äh ist, der äh am Ende mit derselben,
intellektuellen Größe ausgestattet ist wie zum Beispiel Snowden. Das sind Einlassung, ich generell sehr interessant finde,
Lässt sich natürlich jetzt nicht sagen, auch nicht ob's irgendwie er oder sie ist, also noch ist das Ganze halt unter diesem also der John Doe nicht kennt, John Do ist sozusagen so ein bisschen das äh.
Max Mustermann der USA.
Genau ne, also das der Name, der immer so herangeführt wird, wenn man eben keinen anderen Namen mehr haben will,
Ja ähm bin gespannt wie sich das entwickelt. Ich meine wir hatten ja auch diese Fälle des äh schon vor vor Jahren, wo die deutschen Finanzbehörden,
die sogenannten Steuer-CDs äh angekauft haben, in dem Fall mit Informationen über Konten in der Schweiz.
Ja würden die deutschen Behörden dann sozusagen derjenigen, der ihnen das verkauft hat, dann auch gleich verurteilen, wenn sie äh nee. Genauer wissen, wer es ist.
Nee, das hände das ist ja zum Glück in Deutschland ähm da gibt's ja diese Ausnahmeklausel in dem, in dem ähm Datenhedereiparagraphen.
Mittlerweile oder demnächst.
Demnächst hoffen. Nee, das ist ja mit der Vorratsansprechung.
Auch schon beschlossen worden, richt.
Beschlossen worden, also ich weiß nicht, wann das nochmal mit dem in Kraft treten war und so weiter, ja.
Na gut, dann könnte man daraus ja dann auch mal sozusagen sagen, okay, dann sind ja wohl Wissenblauer. Darunter eigentlich auch dann wieder geschützt?
Tja, aber es sieht eben äh in der Realität nicht so aus, ja, dass da mal jemand wirklich seine Ruhe bekommt. Ich meine, der Typ der kritisiert ja zu Recht.
Dass er oder diese Person John Doe kritisiert ja,
zurecht, dass wenn sie entharnt wird, dann gibt's eine ganze Menge Leute, die hinter der Herr sein werden und davor braucht ihr effektiven Schutz und das erste, was sie braucht, ist die Gewissheit, dass Regierung nicht mehr hinter ihr sein werden.
Und dann kann man sich Gedanken machen äh über all die äh äh Mosak äh von Sicker Kunden und Mossak von Circa selber, weil das eben ja gut den Eindruck macht, dass das jetzt nicht unbedingt Leute sind, die sich um.
Funda fundamentale Gesetze dieser Gesellschaft und Prinzipien besonders kümmern, sodass äh diese Person John Doe sicherlich auch ähm.
Da äh nochmal ganz anderen Gefahren ausgesetzt ist, ja?
Er sagte erst, die können mich offenbar gar nicht schützen und zweitens haben wir dann offenbar noch nicht mal ein Interesse daran. Und das ist natürlich schon übel.
Ja man würde sich wünschen, dass auch die Justiz im digitalen Zeitalter ankommt.
Sehr schön. Die Justiz.
Kurzmeldung, frag mich nicht, ich lache nur, lache mal nur kurz drüber. Ich habe ja vor.
Weiß nicht vor ein paar Jahren zu diesem Gesetz damals Stellung genommen als Vertreter des Chaoscomputerclubs und ähm zweitausenddreizehn lese ich hier, muss das gewesen sein. Und da ging es eben darum.
Äh den gerichtlichen Post ein und Ausgang äh weitgehend auf Online-Kommunikation umzustellen. Da haben sie also gesagt, okay, jetzt ist D-Mail und das
EGVP sind jetzt sichere Übertragungsverfahren, damit dürft ihr jetzt Rechtsverkehr machen, das ging vorher nicht, ja? Da konnten die nur Faxen und Briefe schicken. Ähm, die die Kritik
an diesem Verfahren habe ich damals ausführlich geübt. Hm.
Und äh da sei dann drauf verlinkt. Ähm jetzt sagen sie, das wollen sie aber auch.
Für die Strafprozesse haben. Und jetzt wollen sie.
Anfang zwanzig achtzehn sollen dann elektronische Strafprozessakten möglich sein. Und ab Januar zwanzigsechsundzwanzig verpflichtend.
Und eine Strafprozessakte, jetzt haben sie die perfekte Idee, dann kann man so ja.
Die Akteneinsicht zumindest in Zivilverfahren über ein Onlineportal ermöglichen.
Gute Idee.
Mhm. What good passiblic orange.
Ja, das hat also Zivilverfahren da, was weiß ich,
Zeigt jemand an oder du zeigst jemanden an, dann nimmt man sich einen Anwalt und dann verlangt man Akteneinsicht und dann kriegt man irgendwann nach ein paar Wochen äh kriegt der Anwalt und das darf auch nur der Anwalt, kriegt dann eben diese Akte und guckt da rein und sagt dann, ja, pass auf,
Ich sehe hier folgende Beweise ich sehe hier folgende Aussagen, jetzt müssen wir uns mal überlegen äh wie werde ich aus der Nummer rauskriegen oder eben nicht, ja?
Und wenn das dann demnächst irgendwie ist, äh ja okay, ähm guck mal hier ins Onlineportal.
Hacker werden Hacken. Ich sehe das schon. Also eine der Nachrichten zwanzig neunzehn oder sowas, weil die werden das ja zwanzigachtzehn nicht hinkriegen.
Größer.
Wird halt einmal dieser ganz.
Skandal geplatzt wegen Hackerangriff.
Na ja, Politik, Korruptionsskandal wäre am Ende wahrscheinlich kein Zivilverfahren, aber ähm,
Oh man, ey, das ist echt keine gute Idee, sowas digital zu führen und dann auch noch irgendwie äh online zugänglich zu machen, ja. Daneben.
Werden dem Plan nach die Nutzungspflichten für professionelle Rechtsanwender,
Im gerichtlichen Mahnverfahren erweitert, also da müssten sie noch irgend so ein Quatsch ähm.
Äh noch so ein Quatsch drunter, aber jetzt irgendwie elektronische Straf äh Strafprozessakte und Online-Portal zu Akteneinsicht in Zivilverfahren.
Stört dich jetzt mehr die stört dich jetzt mehr die Digitalisierung der Akte oder die Bereitstellung über das Portal oder beides.
Ich würde sagen, das sind äh zwei Dinge, die ähnlich das wird einfach eine Katastrophe. Also das gibt einfach Ärger.
Wer ist zum Beispiel also.
In in einer in der Akte auch irgendwie mal mit einem Computer recherchieren zu können, ist ja durchaus nachvollziehbar.
Das ist nachvollziehbar, aber du hast.
Beweise suchen, Zusammenhänge suchen.
Wäre durchaus wünschenswert, aber du hast bei diesen ganzen Anwaltskanzleien und bei deren Klienten in keiner Form eine ausreichende ähm.
Sicherheit, um um wirklich mit solchen Sachen arbeiten zu können. Du kannst also im Moment, wenn ich das Recht erinnere, ist das so, äh Akteneinsicht hast, dann kann der Anwalt ja halt kopieren, aber der darf sie dem Mandanten zum Beispiel nicht mitgeben.
Und wenn das jetzt hier demnächst über so ein Onlineportal ist, wo die äh reihenweise ausdrucken, jeder drauf zugreifen kann, jeder Hacker reinguckt und dann hast du irgendwie innerhalb von paar Monaten den ersten League mit diesen ganzen Zivilprozessakten, alles offene Verfahren.
Ähm, ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist.
Weiß ich wirklich nicht. Ich habe mir auch den Gesetzentwurf jetzt im Detail noch nicht angeschaut, äh welches.
Welches Verfahren dann dort zum zum Einsatz kommt, wahrscheinlich irgend so ein äh Derby-Flashviewer, der keine Druckfunktion hat oder sowas. Also äh du musst ja dann noch überlegen, die haben ja nicht nur die, die haben ja nicht nur immer die schlechte Idee, sondern da auch noch die schlechteste Idee für die Umsetzung.
Und jetzt geht das, das geht also jetzt erstmal noch in den Bundesrat und in den Bundestag und dann wird darüber weiter beraten. Ähm.
Was wird da zwanzig achtzehn.
So so jetzt der äh der Gesetzesentwurf für dieses für diese neue Auflage des Gesetz.
Zwanzig sechsundzwanzig. Also ähm
Ich freue mich auch, wenn ich irgendwann mal demnächst, auch wenn ich nicht so genaue Vorstellungen davon habe, wann das sein könnte, aber ob wir nicht
irgendwann mal auch so einen gewissen Reifegrad der Gesamteit erreicht haben, der ist sicherlich noch weit entfernt, aber ist ja auch durchaus vorstellbar, dass wir
bestimmte Probleme äh so gut verstanden haben zumindest, auch wenn sie noch eine Weile dann existieren.
Mittelfristig irgendwo mal hinzukommen, wo ein gesteigertes elektronisches Miteinander denkbar wird,
Derzeit ist es, sagen wir mal in in der aktuellen Situation von Betriebssystemen und und und wie Daten ausgetauscht und verarbeitet werden auf System
sind wir glaube ich noch relativ weit davon entfernt, dass man irgendwie sagen kann,
Wir werden schon irgendwas sicher kriegen. Man kann natürlich jetzt auch fatalistisch rangehen und sagen, das wird nie irgendwie in den Griff zu bekommen sein,
Da weiß ich nicht, ob ich da so unterschreiben würde. Ich weiß nur, dass die Herausforderung groß ist. So eine Aussage wie jetzt zwanzig achtzehn machen wir das, ist sicherlich zu früh.
Die Herausforderung ist groß und äh jemand wird sie äh bis zu einem akzeptablen Risikoniveau meistern. Aber das werden nicht die deutschen Justizverwaltungen sein.
Zumindest nicht zwanz.
Ne? Also du musst ja mal die werden das auch nicht selber machen, das ist jetzt dann wieder irgendwie eine Ausschreibung, da werden jetzt irgendwelche Leute irgendwelche Verfahren machen. Da wird wahrscheinlich hängen da schon wieder die ganzen Beratungsputzen drin und machen sich darüber Gedanken, aber ich will da jetzt nicht spekulieren,
Ich sage, das ist eine relativ schlechte Idee. Und ich bin mal gespannt, wer wie schlecht sie die noch umsetzen.
Aber wann ja Kurzmeldung, deswegen kommen wir jetzt zurück zur nächsten. Die Eichhörnchen gewinnen den Cyber-War.
Denn man muss sich ja wirklich fragen, wer sind denn diese ganzen Cyberkrieger, von denen immer die Rede ist, ja? Also äh wir wir hören in zunehmenden Maße von äh Herrscharen, von äh Hackern, mit Maske, die,
wie einst,
Die schottischen Krieger über die Hügel äh äh zogen mit großem Geschrei, so sind sie irgendwie auf unseren Datenbahnen unterwegs und haben nichts besseres äh,
zu tun als unsere Gesellschaft in den Ruinen, unsere Kernkraftwerke in Explosion und die gesamte Welt im Untergang näher zu bringen. Das ist das Szenario, das steht an der Wand,
Und ich finde, da müsste mal sich jemand mal.
Müsste man hier noch was gegen tun.
Genau mal, genau auch mal damit beschäftigen, wer sind eigentlich diese ganzen Angreifer.
Ja
Oder hat das jemand gemacht?
Das, genau das haben sie hier gemacht, da sind äh zwei Forscher hingegangen, das haben sie letzte Woche auf der Fortcom in Chicago präsentiert und sagen,
Es gibt bisher keine einzige bewiesene Cyberattacke, die zu einem Blackout geführt hat,
Hingegen hat es zahlreiche Ausfälle gegeben, die durch Tiere wie Eichhörnchen raten oder Vögel hervorgerufen wurden.
Ähm die haben also eine Karte veröffentlicht ähm und sie sagen natürlich, also sie sahen einen wichtigen Punkt,
Bis zum ersten Mai zweitausendsechzehn wurden drei eintausenddreihundertsechzehn Stromausfälle gemeldet,
In siebenhundertundvierzehn Fällen waren es Eichhörnchen, ja in dreihundertundsechs Fällen Vögel, aber auch Marder oder sieben Schläber und so weiter. In Europa gibt es kaum äh Fälle von Eichhörnchen.
Das liegt daran, dass wir irgendwie weniger von den Viechern rumrennen haben, als die Amerikaner. Und die Amerikaner haben ja auch irgendwie diese aggressiveren Eichhörnchen oder sowas, also äh ich kenne mich da in der äh V.
Grauen, die grauen Eichhörnchen. Mhm.
Aus, ja. Ähm gleichzeitig sagen sie aber natürlich.
Das heißt natürlich nicht, dass es trotzdem, dass es nicht trotzdem möglich ist. Also diese Angriffe auf kritische Infrastrukturen, die Szenarien.
Sind möglich undenkbar, aber wenn man selbst mal auf dieses Buch von Daniel Elsberg schaut, ähm selbst der hat ja Schwierigkeiten ähm.
War doch Elsburg, oder? Ich hoffe, dass wir den hier Elsburg ähm.
Selbst der hat Schwierigkeiten sein für sein sein Gau-Szenario da, ähm einen eine Motivation.
Den Terroristen zu geben. Und äh das scheint auch hier irgendwie
der Fall zu sein. Also die Autoren dieser Studie sagen wir meinen unsere Karte ernst, jedes Ereignis ist bestätigt, das heißt neben dem Cyberspaß ist es uns definitiv ein ernstes Anliegen, der ständigen Kampfrhetorik, dass diese Welt aufgrund von Cyber of
Angriffen auf unser Stromnetz zugrunde gehen wird, etwas entgegenzusetzen.
Fand ich also super geil, dass dass diese Studie da habe ich echt gedacht, boah Mist, die hätte ich echt gerne gemacht, so. Die hätte ich wirklich gerne selber gemacht,
Cyber Scribble One dot com. Sehr schön. Sehr schön. Nee, wirk.
Feine Sache. Morgen kommt dann der Blackout. Weiß es, aber dann können wir immer noch sagen, hey, das ist einer von eintausendvierhundert, ja. Na ja.
Asienkarte ist auch nicht nur in USA, sondern die ist irgendwie.
Nein, nein, die haben das richtig.
Global und aber auch in Deutschland gibt's das ein oder andere Eichhörnchen. Ja, ein älster Werder.
Wesertal.
Und äh auch in Zürich haben sich schon zugeschlagen, also Gefahr im Verzug. Ansonsten haben wir in Deutschland eher Vögel, Mäuse, Ratten.
Oh, oh und es gibt Aufkleber.
Cyberschool, one, Cyberware forever. Scheiße, die kosten fünf Euro, fünf Dollar.
Tja, da geht's hin.
So, dann wisst ihr ja, wo die Spenden hin müssen. So.
Nächstes Ding, hier ein, das machen wir jetzt auch nur kurz zur zum kurzen Thema, weil ich weiß, dass die äh Kollegen bei methodisch Inkorrektors äh ausführlicher behandelt werden. Ich hoffe das ähm.
Jetzt muss ich es auch zum ersten Mal im äh Podcast aussprechen. Elsevier sage ich nämlich, wobei mein Kopf immer sagt, Else vier, aber es ist äh.
Also sagen Ilsevia.
Elsevi, Else vier, die, die mehr oder weniger der größte ähm.
Verlag für Scientific Journals sind, ähm, haben eine Seite äh verklagt, die äh heißt.
Was ist das Problem mit diesem Ganzen? Also das das Verlagswesen mal zusammengefasst. Die,
Gesellschaften, die Volkswirtschaften unterhalten sich Universitäten. Diese Universitäten sollen ähm möglichst.
Wissen,
Neues Wissen durch Forschung generieren an von dem an diesem Wissen soll die Gesellschaft partizipieren davon äh gewinnbringend leben, davon profitieren,
gleichzeitig machen, dass es also der Forschungsteil der Universität. Gleichzeitig machen die Universitäten Leere und wollen damit.
Der Gesellschaft äh Eliten bilden. Ja, Leute, die studiert haben
sind mit dem Wissen der Welt, der aktuellen Forschung konfrontiert worden. Sie haben eine Grundbildung, diejenigen, die promoviert haben, mussten sogar mal selber forschen und sind dann
Eine Wissenselite, eine Bildungselite, die das Land äh voranbringen soll. Und diese diesen gesamten Spaßforschung und Lehre, der wird.
Zumindest mal Grundfinanziert äh durch den Staat und der Besuch der Universitäten,
ist in den weiten Teilen Deutschlands soweit ich das richtig verstehe inzwischen wieder,
kostenlos möglich, ähm, beziehungsweise man zahlt da irgendwie 'ne kleine Gebühr, 'n Semesterbeitrag. Hatten wir auch mal anders, wir hatten Studiengebühren, aber wenn ich das richtig verstehe, sind jetzt überall wieder weggeklagt worden, oder?
Und jetzt geht es bei dieser Forschung darum, die Forschung muss veröffentlicht werden, wenn du eine äh eine Doktorarbeit schreibst, die musst du veröffentlichen, wenn du ein,
Forschungsergebnis produzierst, musst du es veröffentlichen und du möchtest das natürlich möglichst viel Impact tun.
Ähm in renommierten Journals
das stattfinden lassen und renommierte Journals zeichnen sich dadurch aus, dass ein sogenannter Peer-Review Prozess stattfindet. Das heißt, du bist, was weiß ich, Forscher im Bereich der
Persönlichkeitspsychologie und möchtest in dem renommierten Journal äh JPSP veröffentlichen, Journal on Social and Personalit,
Personaltypse. Oder Personality in Social Psychology. Als Beispiel,
Ähm möchtest dadrin veröffentlichen, dann reist du dort ein und dann wird das von diesen von den Aditers entgegengenommen und dann geben die das zwei oder mehreren,
deiner Pierce-Zur äh anonymen Review äh und die geben dann ihr Feedback dazu.
Und dann kriegst du das nochmal zurück und dann wird dein Artikel entweder angenommen oder abgelehnt. Und dann wird der veröffentlicht in diesem Journal. Und dieses Journal kostet Geld.
Viel Geld. Und deswegen ist die Bibliothek der Universität,
An der du diese Forschung durchgeführt hast. Kunde bei dem Verlag, der das Journal hat und kauft dann mitunter deine Forschungsergebnisse, die du Universität ohnehin schon bezahlt hat,
Nochmal von diesem Verlag zurück für viel Geld. Und deswegen gibt es seit langer Zeit oder seit einigen Jahren immer.
Oder um das noch kurz anzuwerfen? Noch schlimmer oder sie tun's nicht, weil sie sich das nicht leisten können,
Was das sozusagen bedeutet, dass obwohl die Forschung irgendwie von deiner eigenen Institut kommst und noch nicht mal Zugriff darauf hast oder beziehungsweise das einfach auch ganze Institute
auch keine Chance haben, sich mit den PayPal auseinanderzusetzen, was eigentlich in ihrem Kernforschungsprogramm der Fall ist. Also das ist wirklich abenteuerlich.
Enorme, enorme Preise, die da gezahlt werden. Das Angebot, was die Verlage machen, ist aber dann auch zum Beispiel so, dass sie dir deine IP-Adressen Whitelisten. Du hast also zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt irgendwie an einer
an der TU einer HU bist, die haben dann eben Verträge
Und wenn du dann auf diese Seiten gehst von so einer IP-Adresse dort, dann steht da nicht äh fünf Euro bezahlen für den Artikel, sondern dann steht da PDF runterladen. Aber das sind eben dann
Rahmen ähm Verträge von schwindelerregenden Summen, ne,
die da äh geschlossen werden. Aber der Zugang zu dieser Forschung grundsätzlich ist erstmal kostenfrei nicht möglich. Und das ist,
Das ist schon allein der Skandal. Das ist allein schon der Skandal. Denn diese Forschung ist in der Regel aus öffentlichen Geldern finanziert und selbst wenn sie es nicht wäre, dann soll sie trotzdem allen zur Verfügung stehen. Sie gilt ja als veröffentlicht,
Sie ist ja auch für jeden verfügbar, nur diese Verlage kassieren eben das Geld. Und die Leistung der Verlage.
An dieser Publikation ist verschwindend gering, denn die äh die Autoren werden ja nicht bezahlt, ganz im Gegenteil,
die Aditers betrachten das in der Regel als Ehre und die Reviewer auch.
Das heißt, dieser Verlag äh das Journal selber äh leistet äh im Prinzip inhaltlich gar keine Arbeit, außer äh daran eben die Urheberrechte zu haben. Also es ist ein ganz, ganz,
schlechter Tumor für das Bildungssystem
und das Bildungssystem ist ja das Allerwichtigste, was wir haben für die Zukunft unserer Gesellschaft. Ich weiß, dass jetzt öfter öfter betone, bei allem so das
das, was wirklich wirklich, wirklich wichtig ist, dass wir nicht mehr so viele Idioten überall haben. Und das geht dadurch, dass wir diese Bildung frei zugänglich machen,
durch nichts anderes. Ähm,
ich kriege heute noch Puls, wenn ich an diese Werbe ähm Werbung der Initiative neue äh soziale Marktwirtschaft äh denke, wo sie irgendwie so meinten, ja hier die Akademiker
ruhen sich auf dem Rücken der Malocher aus oder so. Nein, das ist natürlich und deswegen brauchen wir hier Studiengebühren, damit die Akademiker die Scheiße selber bezahlen können. Das ist natürlich total falsch. Das war das war eine dermaßen, da kriege ich heute noch Puls, weil,
Letztendlich die Freiheit der Bildung ja überhaupt ermöglicht.
Dass wir Akademiker.
Aus allen Schichten Zugang hast dazu,
Akademiker zu werden und eben nicht irgendwie weiß ich nicht wie viel zehntausend Euro im Jahr ausgeben muss an Studiengebühren, die eben jemand der bildungsferner tätig ist, eben auch einfach nicht hat.
Man schaut sich nur die Diskussionen in den USA äh dazu an und
besondere den Wahlkampf von Bernie Sanders, der unter anderem auch deshalb, weil einfach die Mittelklasse, die ohnehin immer kleiner wird, die Fälle davon schwimmen sieht, weil man sich heutzutage eigentlich für einen normalen Halbwegs Erfolg versprechenden Bildungsweg in den USA,
im Prinzip,
hoch verschulden muss und dass das natürlich nochmal eine extra Hypothek ist beziehungsweise Leute, die eben einfach überhaupt gar keine Möglichkeit haben, sich hoch zu verschulden, komplett von solchen Ausbildungswegen abschneidet.
So. Und ein Teil darf ein Teil des Problemes da ist nicht überall Else vier dran Schuld, aber die gehören mit, die gehören mit in den Sack, äh wo man draufhaut und immer den richtigen trifft.
Genau. Es gibt Sales vor allem so,
Zwei Antworten auf diese Malese, auf der das eine kommt sozusagen aus dem akademischen Bereich selbst heraus, das ist der Trend zu
Open Science, äh dem freien Publizieren von Papers. Das ist noch keine große Welle geworden, aber das spielt im zunehmenden Maße eine Rolle. Das mag langfristig hier
auch ein Lösungsweg sein. Der ist allerdings wirklich sehr langfristig, weil einfach dieses Verlagswesen sehr eingespielt ist und weil sich eben auch in der akademischen Welt dieser
diese Vorstellung von wie das so schön heißt renommierten Journals,
die eigentlich selber gar nicht renommiert sind, sondern die sozusagen nur äh der Geldkeeper sind für renommierte Wissenschaftler, die da drin äh publiziert, dass sich eben dieser Ruf lange hält und damit eben dieses System sich äh im Prinzip auch immer wieder selbst
äh stabilisiert.
Dass es dieser Ruf hält sich dadurch, dass Wissenschaftler den natürlich auch messbar gemacht haben. Also äh durch den ich weiß nicht mehr genau wie der berechnbar wie der berechnet wird, aber es gibt den Impactfaktor,
Und äh mit dem wird der Impact eines Journals.
Ähm bewertet, ja? Und du du strebst an.
In den High Impact Journals zu veröffentlichen. Also zum Beispiel kenne ich das aus äh Promotionsordnungen irgendwie so
wenn du jetzt kommulativ promovieren willst, das heißt du schreibst keine Monographie, sondern du veröffentlichst mehrere Artikel, dass du dann eben auch Vorgaben hast bezüglich des Impactfaktors
dass das heißt okay du musst einen Artikel,
Mit Impactfaktor in einem Journal mit Impact Faktor so und so positionieren äh positionieren und zwei in anderen oder drei in anderen oder sowas, ne? Also da der das haben die Wissenschaftler sich natürlich auch messbar gemacht.
Na klar, aber es ist halt ein selbstverstärkender Effekt, weil dadurch, dass das so ist, wir wollen da alle wieder hin und dadurch wird das halt immer wieder genährt. Im Prinzip ist das so ein bisschen so das analoge Äquivalenz zu
Netzwerkfaktoren, die wir heute bei Facebook haben. Ja, warum postet man auf Facebook, weil da sind ja alle und weil da alle sind da da, weil alle posten. Du hast also im Prinzip genau diesen selbst erhaltenden Strudel
aber am Ende nur bedeutet, dass du jemanden hast, der hier äh die Macht ausüben kann und dann äh
quasi auch den Zugang reduziert, beziehungsweise teuer macht, so macht es Elsavier, so macht es auch
Facebook, du erreichst gar nicht mal alle Leute, die an deinen Inhalten interessiert sind. Ganz im Gegenteil, du kriegst sogar noch ausgerechnet wie viel Prozent du jetzt nicht erreicht hast und um die restlichen Prozent auch noch zu bekommen, darfst du nochmal drauflegen. Also es ist schon wirklich ein bisschen anders. Aber es gibt jetzt auch noch eine
zweite Gegenbewegung und die kommt aus dem Netz.
Also Open Access hat man damit jetzt, ne? Ja. Und die, die Gegenbewegung aus dem Netz nennt sich
Ähm eine Seite, die äh also sagen wir, dass das Piratebay der Scientific Papers
Und äh die haben also, kommst du drauf, kannst du suchen und dann gibt's, gibt's im Raubkopien ähm dieser dieser Papers. Und da hat das eben,
auch massiv äh Elsevier getroffen und die waren damit natürlich ein bisschen unglücklich und haben sich dann.
Mit einem Millionen Dollar äh Schadensersatzklage
gegen diese Seite gewährt irgendwo in den USA und das endete erstmal darin, dass diese Seite ihre
Domain verloren hat. Die waren vorher unter äh Punkt.
Äh wie war das denn? Vorher das Punkt org. Dann laut Artikel unter Sihub IO, aber da gab's sie auch nicht mehr und ähm dann jetzt unter ihrer eigenen IP sind sie noch erreichbar und als
Torhüten-Service, Saihab, zwei, zwei, zwei, sechs, sechs, OK CXT Punkt ONIN ist diese Seite noch,
verfügbar,
wie gesagt, eine weitere tiefere Betrachtung erhoffen wir uns bei den Power Usern von methodisch inkorrekt.
Ja, also ich habe äh auch schon mal äh nachgefragt so, ähm welche Bedeutung Sihap äh hat und ja, die Antwort war im Wesentlichen.
Und könnte ich nicht arbeiten. Also vor allem aus dem schon vorhin
geschilderten Problemen, dass halt bestimmte Institute einfach in ihrer eigenen Disziplin sich einfach diesen Zugang auf genau die Papers nicht erlauben können, die für diese Arbeit einfach nennenswert relevant ist und äh,
Wie damals auch schon Paritbay halt einfach Zugang zur Kultur gut geschaffen ähm und ignoriert an der Stelle einfach die existierende Urheberrechtslage, weil sie halt einfach sagen,
Jahr meinetwegen, aber es muss halt trotzdem sein.
Und äh ja, ne, toury move all Barriers in the way of Science, das ist so ein bisschen der der Slogan, das Ganze ist von einer Dame aus Kasachstan mal angestoßen worden und die verschiedene das halt auch ähm
quasi so als Gerilla äh Projekt,
Gibt da auch diesen schönen Guerilla Open Excess Begriff, der in einem entsprechenden Manifest ähm von ähm Aaron Schwarz glaube ich äh,
mal äh festgeschrieben wurde, worauf sich das auch halt wenig beruft. Sozusagen der radikale Flügel der Open Excessbewegung.
Ja. Wir freuen uns über die Werbung, äh die ich habe, dadurch äh erfährt.
Genau, also wenn ihr so Akademiker seid und ihr habt euch immer mal gefragt, warum ihr eigentlich keine Papers habt. Ne? Müsst ihr jetzt auch. Es läuft.
Das US-Geheimgericht Fisk,
Intelligence the Valincord hat im vergangenen Jahr mal wieder keinen einzigen Antrag der Geheimdienste auf elektronische Überwachungsmaßnahmen abgelehnt. Äh so genehmigte der Fisk,
alle eintausendvierhundertsiebenundfünfzig Überwachungsanträge.
Ach, wirklich.
Das waren noch einmal einhundert mehr als im Jahr zuvor. Und insgesamt äh wurden im vergangenen Jahr auch achtundvierzigtausendsechshundertzweiundvierzig National Security Letter,
beantragt äh und mehr als drei Viertel davon äh hatten sich gegen äh Ausländer gerichtet,
National Security Letters dadurch bekannt geworden, dass äh Lavabit, der Internet der E-Mail-Provider von Edwards Norden.
Sich dagegen gewehrt hatte einen derartigen Folge zu leisten ebenso viele Jahre vorher äh Nikolas,
Mary.
Und es geht weiter mit den Zugriffen auf unsere Daten. Eine US-Richterin hat eine iPhone-Entsperrung per Fingerabdruck angeordnet. Ähm.
Da geht es um einen neunundzwanzigjährige, die angeblich Freundin, die Freundin eines armenischen Gängenmitglieds ist.
Ähm die Gerichtsunterlagen selber bleiben aber unter Verschluss und die Frage ist jetzt äh durftet ihr das oder nicht? Die US-Juristen sind sich darüber uneins ähm die einen sagen, ja ähm.
Wenn du nämlich den Fingerabdruck dadrauf legst. Also du hast ja, du hast grundsätzlich ein Aussageverweigerungsrecht.
Du musst dich nicht selber belasten. Und jetzt sagen die, wenn du ein Telefon da liegen hast und das Telefon ist,
Passwort geschützt? Dann ist es ein Wissen, was du hast, wie man dieses Passwort eingibt und dieses musst du nicht herausgeben.
Das wäre ein Wissen aus deinem Kopf, was dazu beitragen kann, dich selber zu belasten, also musst du es nicht rausgeben,
Andere sagen aber, na ja, wenn das jetzt mit dem Fingerabdruck aufgemacht wird, dann kann man das ja vergleichen mit einem Haustürschlüssel.
Und wenn der Richter nun mal eine Wohnungsdurchsuchung anordnet, dann kannst du nicht unter äh Berufung auf das Zeugnisverweigerungsrecht den Schlüssel nicht herausgeben, weil dann treten sie die Tür ein. Insofern sagen sie hier.
Äh
Gehen sie hier davon aus, dass diese Entsperrung in Ordnung ist? Ähm noch dazu beim iPhones spielt ja dann auch Zeit eine Rolle. Also ich glaube, wenn du vierundzwanzig Stunden das nicht benutzt hast, dann verlangt das auf jeden Fall wieder den Code,
ich weiß nicht, was sich da jetzt was da jetzt passiert. Ähm.
Man könnte jetzt natürlich überlegen, ob man diesen äh ob man diesen Fall irgendwie vor ein Gericht bringt.
Also ob man das äh durchkämpft, je nachdem äh wie wie mutig oder wie engagiert die Anwälte sind, werden sie das halt auch tun. Äh aber das bleibt natürlich ein,
ein weiteres äh Problem, zumal natürlich dazu kommt, dass äh anordnen ist eben eine Sache. Es gibt ja dann auch noch die Gummelknüppelanordnung, die einem in anderen Ländern,
zuteil werden kann, deswegen wird's eigentlich dringend Zeit, dass man jetzt mal das umgesetzt kriegt mit diesen falschen Fingern, ne, dass man irgendwie sagt, okay,
Äh wenn du den, wenn du den falschen Finger dreimal draufhältst, dann lösche ich halt einfach alles, weil dann wurdest du gerade gezwungen.
Ne? Also es wäre so eine der Ideen, diese Fingerabdruckgeschichte mal in den Griff zu krie.
Ja, also es gibt auf jeden Fall, wenn du's dreimal falschen Finger genommen hast, dann fragt er wieder nach einem Passbrot.
Ja, ich will aber, dass er, dass ich einen bestimmten Finger habe.
Dass er dann sofort löscht. Ach so, dass man sozusagen ein einen expliziten Löschfinger sozusagen hat. So der kleine Finger und weg sind die Daten.
Kleiner Finger wäre zu unauffällig, du musst halt einen Zeigefinger oder sowas nehmen, ne.
Anderen sozusagen.
O hat nicht geklappt, damit's dir beim ersten Mal nicht passiert, dann sagst du, oh, sorry, ja, nee, klar vor. Und beim zweiten Mal Arsch lecken. Soweit, so willst du das haben.
Bin ich von, bin ich mir sicher?
So, dann haben wir äh ein ein bisschen Ärger oder ein bisschen Raunen um das Torprojekt, aber das ist äh na ja.
Mit.
Edman hat äh eine Zeit lang zum Torprojekt Contribute,
insbesondere zu der Komponente Videa, das ist dieses äh so ein äh da kannst du dann eben
im Prinzip dem Torprozess äh Einstellung geben. Wie jetzt zum Beispiel, wie sie also der
Tor hat selber ein ein Socket, auf dem es äh nach Authentifizierung Befehle entgegennimmt, wie zum Beispiel wechsel mal die IP-Adresse äh mach mal eine neue äh Identity auf oder mache mal neue Circles oder sowas
und äh Vitauia ähm ist dazu ein Interface gewesen. Daran hat er äh gearbeitet.
Dass so ein Gui quasi.
Na gut für für Tor, ja.
Um die Bedienung eben zu vereinfachen. Und äh zweitausenddreizehn wurde es aufgegeben, beziehungsweise nicht wirklich aufgegeben, sondern eigentlich mehr oder weniger in den Torbrowser reingemercht, würde ich eher sagen. Ähm also ich.
Aber genau die genauen, der genaue Verlauf des der Codes ist mir da nicht bekannt, der Typ auf jeden Fall.
Nach seinem Studium dann eine Position bei der Myter Cooperation ein, äh die bekannt dafür ist, dass sie die äh CVE Liste führt, also die,
Oh, jetzt sind wir grade erst eh nicht ein. Kamen, Valenobility.
Weiß ich gerade nicht, wo äh Sicherheitslücken im Prinzip katalogisiert werden äh auch nach ihrem Impact äh.
Ah okay. Äh wo eben Sicherheitslücken gesammelt werden als als Datenbank, damit man äh na ja, einmal eine Referenzpunkt hat, was die Sicherheitslücke ist, andererseits immer weiß, wo es gerade neue gibt und ähm.
Da sind die also äh äh beschäftigt und die so da kriegt eben jede Sicherheitslücke eine eindeutige Nummer
Wie wie beantragst du dann auch, ne? Schickst du da hin, sagst du hier und dann kriegst du irgendwann deine CVE Nummer zurück und dann macht das alles sehr viel einfacher. Ähm und ab zweitausendzwölf wurde dieser äh Mad Admin dort mit Aufgaben betreut
der die in dem Bereich der Unterstützung der US Polizei,
vielen, also er sollte den helfen, kriminell zu suchen und war dann eben als Consultant direkt bei der Remote-Operation Unit is FBI
später auch dann bei unter anderen Arbeitgebern jeweils für das FBI. Und dann wurde im Laufe der Zeit,
äh zu einem wichtigen Teil der Operation Torpedo, die Mitte zwanzig vierzehn dadurch bekannt wurde, dass sie im Darknet ähm,
Webseiten mit kinderpornografischen Inhalten sowie deren Nutzeridentifizierte. Und ähm.
Wie sie es gemacht haben, war ein äh Flash Exploid, das äh es geschafft hat.
Ähm,
den den Browser oder den mit dem, der äh Nutzer auf diese äh Seite zugreift, dazu zu bringen, ein Paket zu schicken außerhalb
der Torkette, also Tor funktioniert ja so. Du hast dann immer ein ähm.
Im Prinzip für den Browser ist Thor ein Socksproxy und der Talkprozess selber äh kümmert sich dann um das Verteilen der äh,
der Daten auf den verschiedenen Circles die Tor ausmachen
Und wenn du es jetzt schaffst den den Browser oder ein Plug-in, in dem Fall das Flash-Plug-in dazu zu bringen, außerhalb dieser Social-Verbindung ein
ein Päckchen abzusenden mit seiner richtigen IP-Adresse, dann hast du natürlich den Besucher identifiziert,
Und das war das, äh wie sie äh zwanzig vierzehn oder eben auch im Verlauf zwanzig dreizehn.
Eben Darknet Leute angegriffen haben und das ist natürlich jetzt ein,
Unschöner eine unschöne Neuigkeit, dass es ausgerechnet ein ehemaliger Torentwickler war, der daran oder ein ein,
Tor Contributa war, der äh daran beteiligt war, andererseits aber eben auch jemand, der,
zu nichts anderem Zugriff hatte, als das was ohnehin Robben Source ist, Tor is Open Source.
Und äh da sollte, da gibt's jetzt glaube ich keinen wirklichen Anhaltspunkt äh den Verrat äh zu wittern.
Trotzdem war die Aufregung groß.
Nicht nicht unbegründet, ne? Also ähm es gibt da noch andere,
Dinge, also ist das FBI und Tor sind ja jetzt ohnehin nicht so die dicksten Freunde so, ne? Also,
diesen ganzen Kanegimellen, Geschichten und so und es gibt äh Berichte darüber, dass ähm
Torkernentwickler und Entwicklerinnen von FBI Agenten irgendwie immer wieder ähm belästigt werden und so und das ist halt natürlich irgendwie insgesamt so eine.
Eine unschöne ähm Geschichte, die da irgendwie äh stattfindet,
Ich habe in dem Rahmen dann mal nachgefragt, wieso überhaupt der Talkrowser Flash unterstützt hat und äh auch kein AdBlocker drin hat.
Antwort darauf ist dann eben, na ja, weil es so, weil es so ärgerlich ist, dass die Edblocker selber wieder ohne Ende ihrer Nutzer äh tracken und dass es halt den den die Torbrowser Leute ausreichend damit beschäftigt sind
diesen scheiß Torbrowser irgendwie mal abzudichten, dass jetzt nicht auch noch ein ein Werbeblocker mit darein bauen können.
Obwohl das in gewisser Hinsicht.
Das ist ein.
Teil dieser Ziels der Anonymisierung äh sein.
Die Anonymisierung ist ja dadurch erledigt, dass du über den Torbrowser kommst, deswegen ist es kann's dir ja egal sein, dass da jetzt irgendwie so ein Werbenetzwerk gleichzeitig noch sieht, dass dieser IP auf hundertachtzig Seiten gleichzeitig rumsurft,
Aber klar im Prinzip äh sollte man sich darüber Gedanken machen. Ich will da jetzt nicht äh.
Ich meine, die Identifizierung über die IP-Adresse ist ja das eine, man kann ja auch äh im Browser Fingerprinting Maßnahmen sozusagen ergreifen, wenn man da überhaupt erstmal kurz.
Da denken sie natürlich sehr viel drüber nach. Also Torbrowser der macht sich da Unmengen an Gedanken drüber, zum Beispiel startet der immer mit der gleichen Fenstergröße bei allen,
Wenn du die Fenstergröße änderst, sagt er, wenn du jetzt die Fenstergröße änderst, dann wirst du Fingerprintbar,
weil der Top Roser hat alles, was irgendwie an äh an Fingerprint-Möglichkeiten bietet, eben versucht zu zu unterbinden,
Ähm da bis da sind die ausreichende fast so. Na ja.
Meiner meckert hier nicht.
Wer meckert nicht? Wurbelsäule? Ja, du hast wahrscheinlich in der uralte Version, dann sollte er darüber werden, wo sollte er oben links blinken, dass er alt ist. Ja, wenn die Größe änderst.
Frisch aktualisiert.
Dann hast du das weggeklickt, der macht das auf jeden Fall.
Nee, ich habe hier gleich weggeklickt.
Gut, dann hast du den, fährst du den? Ähm nervt mich nicht so viel, wo das er tut ist. Bei dir nicht, äh musste man mit äh Met Adman drüber sprechen.
Ich rufe einfach gleich beim FBI an.
So und dann haben wir noch eine letzte Meldung ähm aus dem Bereich des äh Modellflugsports.
Äh der Herr Minister äh Dobrindt hatte im Herbst schon eine Novellierung der Luftverkehrsordnung angekündigt und nun werden die Modellflieger äh nervös.
Weil sich darin mögliche Verschärfungen
verstecken können. Der deutsche Modellfliegerverband hat deshalb Anfang April die Initiative Pro Modellflug Hände weg von meinem Hobby gegründet
und äh er war dann irgendwie beim Staatssekretär des Bundesverkehrsministeriums. Äh und zwar geht es da hauptsächlich wohl um eine Begrenzung der Flughöhe.
Ähm denn es steht wohl gerade zur Debatte, dass ähm.
Die bisherigen Regelungen für kommerziell genutzte ähm Drohnen auf die privat genutzten,
überführt werden. Das wären dann also
auf die privat genutzten Quadrokopter hauptsächlich. Da wird aber dann kein Unterschied mehr zu Modellflugzeugen gemacht werden. Und das könnte dazu führen, dass dann den Modellflug
in seiner jetzigen Form das ausdroht, weil sie nicht mehr über hundert Meter hoch fliegen dürfen.
Und die weisen darauf hin, dass äh.
Sie sehr viel bessere Kontrolle über Fluggerät haben und ähm
Vor allem, wenn sie mehr Spielraum bei der Höhe haben. Also das kann ich zugeben, äh kann ich zustimmen. Ähm ich habe auch einen Modellflugzeug und ich hab's auch einmal geflogen und habe
Panik und äh je höher das war, desto entspannter war das eigentlich, weil du dann noch ein bisschen mehr Zeit hast, bis das am Boden zerschellt und du kannst dann nochmal korrigieren. Ähm insofern ist Höhe beim Modellflugzeugen prinzipiell erstmal,
Sicherheit. Ähm ist er bei Verkehrsflugzeugen nicht anders. Wenn du da oben bist, dann kannst du wenigstens noch,
weißt du wenigstens, dass du noch einiges an Distanz zurücklegen kannst, äh bis du irgendwann äh am Boden zerschällst. Und da äh machen jetzt also die Modellpfleger äh äh.
Jetzt irgendwie äh eine Initiative geben gegen die Regulierung im Luftraum.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist die derzeitige maximale Flughöhe, die erlaubt ist beim Modellfluglied bei dreihundert Metern.
Kann nur gut sein, ja?
Also ich lese das jetzt gerade so aus dem Internet äh quer. Ähm von daher kann ich das jetzt nicht mit abschließender Bestimmtheit äh von mir geben,
Gibt aber auch schon sozusagen jetzt im Prinzip damit äh auch.
Das Problem, das Sportflugzeuge theoretisch bis auf hundertfünfzig Meter herunterdürfen. Also es gibt da sozusagen jetzt eh schon überschneiden,
Ob das jetzt so ein großes Problem schon ist oder ob hier nur theoretisch ein äh großes Problem gesehen wird, weiß ich nicht. Äh diese hundert Meter, die hier vorgeschlagen wurden, wären sozusagen die,
spürbarer Abtrennung dieser beiden Bereiche. Tja. Das ich meine,
bezieht sich das jetzt wohl nur auf diese Flughöhe, ähm die generell dahinter stehende Frage ist ja überhaupt inwiefern ist eine Regulation von,
Drohnen, Modellflugzeugen, Selbstfliegende, Devices, ähm künftig überhaupt geboten,
wünschenswert oder erforderlich, dass halt ich für ein schweres, schwieriges Thema.
Da wir es auch hier wiederum mit mehreren Interessen,
zu tun haben, ja? Da könnte man jetzt sozusagen hier wie dem Modellflieger äh argumentieren mit ja hier Hobby, Sport, was wollt ihr denn eigentlich? Wo ist das Problem? Ich fliege halt hier rum und alles ist supi, ne?
Auch nachvollziehen, weil das ist irgendwie in äh wahrscheinlich in den meisten Fällen auch äh so. Andererseits sehen wir natürlich auch die technologische Entwicklung,
noch gar nicht so lange her, vor zehn Jahren, da war diese ganze Quadrukopter, Drohnengeschichte, ähm,
Eigentlich noch gar kein Thema, aber dadurch, dass diese Systeme jetzt existieren und auch wirklich rasant besser werden und äh sich auch im Preis immer weiter absenken und äh schon fast zu so einem Massenphänomen werden, also so,
als Weihnachtsgeschenk steht das schon hoch im Kurs und bildet ja auch neue Sportarten aus, ne? Also also dieses First Person,
Rennen, die jetzt zum Beispiel abgehalten werden, haben meiner Meinung nach das das Potenzial nochmal so eine ganz dicke Nummer zu werden. Also wo man quasi so einen Laden in der Livekamera äh eine eine Drohne fliegt und steuert.
Andererseits äh wirft es natürlich auch Fragen auf im Bereich von Privatsphäre, ja? Was ist jetzt sozusagen mit Drohnen, die über alle Gärten, Schweben, Privateigentum
rumfilmen oder die überhaupt im öffentlichen Raum äh äh Dinge tun, ja. Bis hin natürlich äh,
Terrorkeule, die wir natürlich in dieser Debatte auch schon gesehen haben,
Horrorszenarien, die halt jetzt ausgemalt werden, wo ich auch sagen muss, die sind auch vielleicht nicht ganz so weit hergeholt, weil natürlich 'ne, 'ne Drohne, auch 'n,
ideales Wegel ist, um Dinge irgendwohin zu befördern, ohne dass eine Person damit direkt assoziert sein muss und dann haben wir natürlich gerade so in Mexiko äh amerikanischen Grenzbereich drohen die natürlich auch eins A
Kuriere sind für verbotenes Gut, also es ist sozusagen diese Gesamtfrage, die sich jetzt hier stellt und ich.
Bisschen Schiss vor dieser ganzen Debatte muss ich sagen. Weiß nicht, wie du das so siehst.
Ich finde, ja, das ist also es ist es sind Spielzeuge, ja? Also ich sehe da irgendwie.
Ja, in den meisten Fällen sind es Spielzeuge, aber es wird nicht so lange so bleiben.
Ja, es gibt ja dann schon diese Urteile irgendwie, da fliegt einer über den Garten oder ja, ach ja, ich, also ich habe da leider in Deutschland wenig Hoffnung, dass das äh dass man dass man das Ding irgendwie mit Vernunft geklärt kriegt,
Da sehe ich wenig äh Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Denkbar? Na gut, müssen wir jetzt auch nicht weiter vertiefen. Wenn nicht magst.
Modellflug. Ich mache das einfach. Tempelhofer Feld darf man.
Also es ist es ist natürlich also,
Natürlich regulieren die das. Ich weiß nicht, sie können vielleicht am Anfang sich mal irgendwelche Statistiken angucken wer überhaupt, wann, von solchen Dingern jemals zu Schaden gekommen ist,
von diesen, also ich denke schon, da wird's ein paar Unfälle geben. Es gibt ja auch Haftpflichtversicherungen für so einen Modellflieger und so. Ähm,
Aber dass da wird das, da können wir jetzt mal wieder alle richtig deutsch sein und irgendeine Höhenbegrenzung für die Dinger einführen und Führerschein oder so.
Darf scheinen für äh das kann mir alles sehr gut vorstellen.
Ninus und lange Sendung.
Das war eine lange Sendung, deswegen habe ich jetzt auch.
Weil wir ja auch jetzt eine Woche nichts äh haben senden können und äh nächste Woche müssen wir nochmal gucken. Nächste Woche musst du höher überlegen. Muss ich mir was überlegen.
Nächste Woche musst du die Würde überlegen. Danach die Woche auch.
Woche danach auch, bis sie auf äh Fernreisen.
Nach die Woche auch, ja, dann warst du viel zu tun, muss man gucken. Ja.
Was bis jetzt drei Wochen weg oder was? Ja. Wir können natürlich auch die Weindesse der der Fernkommunikation äh.
Nee, das ist mir zu viel Zeitunterschied.
So weit weg bisse.
Weit weg finde ich. Machen wir nicht.
Oder ich reise hinterher.
Kannst du machen? Ich zeige dir gleich, wo ich hinfliege. Ist ganz geil.
Wird teuer, wird teuer.
Weiß nicht, ich komme drauf an, was du verdienst, ne. Wer hat der kann?
Na ja, Blätter.
Leute, das war's ähm hört euch die Sendung zur Not nochmal an. War ja toll und dann äh.
Genau. War eine lange Sendung, wenn ihr sie zweimal hört, habt ihr doppelt so lange Spaß.
Mindestens so viel Spaß wie wir. Wir sagen tschüss.
Und auf Wiederhören.